Yeah,
boom.
And we live,
what are you doing Greg?
I'm looking at the title of a book.
I want to talk about which book?
It's an audio book and it was about reconstruction.
Oh,
what we were just talking about with slaves.
Yeah.
And it was about how,
you know,
once the,
uh,
um,
once the slaves were freed,
they still perpetuated slavery by,
um,
it's called a,
and I got to find it by slavery by another name by Douglas Douglas Blackmon.
And it's about how they would,
they had,
they'd put loitering laws in all around the country and they would find black
people.
And if they were standing around,
they would arrest them.
Or if there was like a petty larceny or a domestic violence thing,
they'd arrest them for fucking two years with the trial with one judge and no
jury.
And the judge was very often a,
a,
a magistrate of the coal mining company.
They'd send the,
the,
the prisoner to a coal mine for two years where he'd worked seven days a week
with shackles on and they would fucking whip them.
And if they tried to escape,
they tracked them down with dogs and they beat them sometimes to death.
And this went on for fucking decades.
Jesus.
Yeah.
So people talk about,
well,
slavery ended back at,
no forms of slavery went on for a long time.
Not only that slavery ended and what effort was done to sort of rectify the
situation,
whatever it was done to like try to give even opportunities for people grew up
in African American cities that were predominantly slaves before 1865 yeah.
Like what,
what's ever been done?
40 acres and a mule.
Do they ever get that?
Is that real?
I don't know.
I think it was a,
but even,
even if you're dealing with that,
even if some people got 40 acres and a mule,
like what is that enough now?
Like the whole thing is crazy.
Like if you have an entire country that the ancestors that did most of the work
did it against their will and then you just like,
yeah,
well you don't have to do that anymore.
And then people are like,
we want reparations and white people are like,
that was 100 years.
Do you know?
And at Georgetown you read about this,
Georgetown University is um,
giving reparations to the slaves that built the university so that the families
of the slaves,
they tracked him down with like 23 and me or one of those companies and they,
they,
they're fucking knocking on doors and they're like,
hey,
are you blah,
blah blah?
Well,
your great,
great grandfather built Georgetown University and they're assessing the
students.
I don't think it's official yet,
but it looks like it's happening.
My concern,
they're assessing the students like 50 bucks each,
something my big
concern.
So it's going to go in the other way.
They're going to track down people's DNA and going to go,
we found out that your family profited from slavery.
Like yeah,
I'm 22 yeah,
right.
What the fuck did I do?
Yeah,
give me all your money,
all of your money,
all your ill gotten gains.
And you'd be like,
but no,
no,
no.
My Dad had a legitimate job.
He worked for H and r block and this and that.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But his grandfather got his money to raise his dad because he had slaves.
Yeah.
Well listen.
Schwartzenegger his grandfather and ss [inaudible] we're going to talk about
that.
He was a hazy.
Yes.
Grandfather was,
he was a green shirt.
Whoa.
What do you know?
Like there's a kid named John Gotti,
the third John Gotti,
the gangsters grandson,
and he's an MMA fighter.
Oh,
no shit.
And it's good.
No Shit.
Good.
Yeah.
Wow.
So far he's fighting on these,
a small promotions,
but he's fucking people up and jacked.
Wow.
Yeah.
I remember John,
cause I lived,
uh,
on Mulberry Street in,
I remember they had a lace and it was a fucking 10 minute apartment and
downstairs,
literally downstairs in one door over was the raven.
I'd Social Club,
which was where Gadi met on Wednesday nights.
All the bosses would pull up and the,
uh,
the Kappos and I don't know the terms,
but they lined up fucking limos.
You stayed up Mulberry Street.
Oh yeah.
They'd walk up and down the street smoking cigars and John Gotti junior was kind
of in charge at that time,
which I guess would be this guy's father.
Yes.
And uh,
he,
it wasn't known as being that sharp and uh,
well the family kind of fell apart since then.
Well,
I don't think there's a,
I think the FBI just had unlimited resources,
government backing,
and they slowly pick the fucking the organization apart and then it's got people
to rat on each other.
They bugged the Raven I social club.
They got inside and they bug it.
And then when they found out it was bugged,
the,
uh,
the wise guys would walk up and down Mulberry Street and talk about their
business.
So the cars on the route,
they bugged the hubcaps of the car is on the route.
You heard about that?
Yeah.
Well that was always the thing about that guy,
that chin,
what's his name?
Uh,
the chin.
Gigante how the fuck do you say his name?
Vincent.
The Chin.
And he was crazy,
but he wasn't crazy,
but he would act crazy.
So He'd walk around with the phone in the bathroom.
Right.
Cause he was up on trial.
He was out on bail.
He was out of his fucking mind.
Wander through the streets with a bathrobe on.
Played crazy.
That's him just walking around.
I'm crazy.
That would be fun Tim too.
That'd be fun to pretend you're crazy.
I think he was actually the guy that they got with the hubcaps.
Oh yeah.
Maybe what?
Maybe they use that tactic more than once.
Yes.
These guys,
you know,
they,
they had a fucking neighborhood where they would go to and when they were in
that neighborhood that was there,
their territory.
Right.
Like when you were living there,
was that going on?
Like he was out of jail.
That was on,
he was in jail.
He was in jail when you yeah,
but they still,
they still showed up.
Most of the guys I think,
I think they're really,
headquarters is more in Brooklyn,
but they still came back to Mulberry Street and it is literally across the
street was a Saint Patrick School,
which is where Robert De Niro and Scorsese went to school as kids.
And where you remember the film mean streets that was shot.
Remember they jump over the wall into the cemetery.
That's,
that's a Saint Patrick school and it's across from the Raven night social club.
Fuck.
I don't remember anything about that movie.
I remember the movie,
but I don't remember anything about what happened and I need to see that one
again.
Yeah,
I need to see that one again.
You know what I saw again recently?
Bullet.
Oh,
set it up,
Wayne.
You see it on a plane.
I think I did see they show it on a plane now and United or something.
What are that fucking,
that's my car.
I saw that movie when I was young and I said,
I want that fucking 69 fastback Mustang.
That's a bad ass car.
Yeah.
68 is it 68 67 or 68 [inaudible] 68 is a very specific shape that the 68 had.
They had like the best rear end.
It's a beautiful though.
They had really cool set up with the rear tail tail lights at 68 it was a little
broader.
It's just,
it was weird looking,
real unusual in compared to some of the other most sites.
But I love it.
Yeah.
And it's my favorite,
I think.
And you watch those movies like that and you realize you think it's going to be,
there's one big car chase.
That's it.
Yeah.
And it's long.
It's a long slow,
but you know,
different,
they were different.
They weren't afraid to do a tracking shot for two minutes with no dialogue.
Just fucking follow a guy walking,
walking down the street.
You'll,
we just assume people are stupid as fuck.
And because of comments and because stupid people want to comment so often the
signals all skewed towards stupid.
You know,
like a movie.
Like,
did you ever see La Mons was Steve Mcqueen,
great.
Steve McQueen movie.
There's no talking at all for the first x amount of minutes of the movie is no
talking.
It's just cars racing.
Right.
And him driving around and shit.
Yep.
There's no talking.
Yeah.
And if you were a movie theater today,
there was no talking.
People are like,
is this broken?
I know fucking part where the guy to talk,
God fucking ties look there is in the original 68 Mustang and that's also a 68
charger though.
He's in a race with the original 68 Mustang.
I think just went for sale thing.
Somebody just bought it.
Look at that.
Do you mean the one from this movie?
Yeah,
that hero cars.
Yeah.
Wrecked a few of these fuckers.
Fuck yeah.
If they're doing like how many cars did they wreck and gone with gone in 60
seconds.
That Nicholas cage movie,
we drove that Eleanor Mustang.
Yeah,
we'll do it.
You know I a bunch of those.
How many fucking orange challenges do you think they needed to get for a hazard?
Oh my God.
I mean they wrecked when in every episode.
That to me is one of the more interesting episodes in our culture that that
show,
which was beloved part of
our past is now taboo.
You'll never find it anywhere because the confederate flag on the roof and when
we were kids that came over here,
it's fucking KKK.
It's racism.
It's white sheets.
When we were kids.
It meant the south.
Yeah.
It didn't mean the same thing.
There's a fucking poster that I have over the pisser from Leonard Skinner
concert from like set some,
sometime during the 70s they have a giant confederate flag behind them.
[inaudible] stage.
Yeah,
but it didn't mean they were racist.
It meant they were from the south.
But somewhere along the line it shifted.
This is where the argument gets weird,
right?
Because people will say,
hey,
it's not about that.
It's about southern pride.
I understand it used to be about southern pride,
but now unfortunately that flag is now connected to racism.
So you're sending out a bad signal.
So what you want that flag to mean for you,
that's great.
But what that flag means for other people is now changed.
And you either accept that or you know you're fighting against it.
Oh,
you can't get me to fucking at this means this to the people don't,
there's,
they're not thinking.
People don't have time to rationally consider whether or not you're racist or
whether or not you're from the south.
What are you,
why do you have that flag?
They don't have time to consider that,
that just go,
oh,
you must be in the KKK.
Oh you must hate black people.
Oh Bang,
there it is racist.
You got that flag.
So some something shifted like really radically and deduce it hazardous like a
great metric of it.
So one of the great things in our culture we could use to measure and you know,
look what happened.
You had a hit show that literally sparked a type of clothing.
The daisy dukes for gay men.
Yeah.
And for girls that are really sad,
like we see a girl with Davidson Daisy dukes like,
sweetie,
you don't need that.
You're hot without it.
Oh are you kidding me?
So hard in those days.
I just went to a food truck before I got here and it was an Asian girl and like
my favorite kind of Asian girl,
she was a belief Filipino big lips.
Oh Tad dark tan with daisy Dukes,
open toed sandals,
beautiful feet,
nice pedicure.
We freaking out.
It was,
it was just me and her so I couldn't stay there and it was so painful.
He ever like,
you're fighting your neck like don't fucking turn,
keep your head straight.
Here's what's interesting and this is the dynamic.
There's a difference between men and women.
If we were to say,
describe,
describing it's the exact same thing,
but you were a girl and you were describing a guy,
it would be innocent.
Yeah,
it would be nothing.
It wouldn't be creepy.
It'd be like that girl.
So horny.
Oh my God.
Like if she was like,
I was in line and behind me was Jason Mamoa.
You know aqua man.
Oh my God.
And if you think he looks good and movies,
he looks so good in real life,
sweetie.
I couldn't stop.
I was looking right at his deck.
I looked at his dick and I looked at his face,
I looked his dick and he started smiling when I started nodding.
And no one would care.
No,
you say that girls liberated.
She's free.
She's crazy.
There goes wild.
But she could maybe grab it on the way out.
Talia,
little give a little tap,
tap,
tap.
No one's going to call the cops.
Right?
But if that's the difference,
and that's what's,
I think this is something that as men,
this is a shaky one because there are definitely some fake male feminists out
there that are just doing it because they want women to love them and they say a
bunch of shit that really screws the curve up.
But if you're being honest and you're being rationally have to realize that the
way a woman perceives being hit on is going to be way different than the way a
guy does cause the girls in danger.
She's in potential danger.
Like legitimately like if you are some fucking serial killer,
a psychopath,
and you decided to follow her back to her house that's on the menu that's on the
menu.
How rare is it that you meet a girl somewhere and she wants to come back to your
house and kill you?
Yeah,
pretty fucking real.
Yeah.
I lean war knows that monster for the Charlie's Thuram movie.
Oh yeah.
That girl prostitute and she would,
she would pick guys up and they would think they were going to go get laid and
she'd kill them.
Right.
And they were all so it wasn't,
you know,
people can demonize the John Because he's picking up a hardcore hooker cause he
wants some sex.
They see it's not victimless.
Yeah.
But you know,
he just wants sex.
He doesn't want to get murdered,
you know,
but she was tortured and you know,
abused so horribly in her life that men became the enemy.
Yeah.
There's a big lesson in that man.
I've,
I've known guys and watch them as they got older and like failed relationship
after failed relationship where they start to developing this like resentment
towards women.
You know,
this is a,
this is like a,
a deep seated like fuck them.
All they want is this and all they want to cause what they're getting from the
women all the time is negative.
They're getting a rejection because they're trying to get laid there.
Didn't want the women that touch them and the women are like,
well not really in touch in you and you're like fuck these wars.
And they eventually develop this thing where they just hate.
Isn't there a name for those guys?
Misogynists no,
there's like an online sale.
And say,
yeah,
insults are guys who,
I think mostly they're talking about like,
look,
a lot of those guys are like genetically unfortunate.
Yeah,
fucked up bone structure room small and that's why there's an argument for
legalized prostitution because there are men that just because of deformities or
whatever reason,
or maybe they're,
maybe they're even a neurotic where they can't hit on a woman and so there
should be a place where a woman can knowingly and confidently and safely be a
prostitute.
Yes,
yes.
It should be your option.
The problem is we equate prostitution with two things that are horrible.
Sexual abuse and sex slavery,
sex trafficking.
We equate prostitution with those things.
That's why like when Robert Kraft got busted,
one of the first things they said is this guy's a billionaire and he was
participating in sex trafficking.
That's they accused him of,
but then they had to drop that.
I don't know if you know that now,
so there was no sex trafficking there.
There was prostitutes,
there was women who wanted to have sex for money and they weren't,
they didn't come over in a seal tanker and slept in the no,
they were prostitutes.
Yeah.
You know,
and it's their choice and they,
you don't hear much about that.
This,
the sex trafficking was like a big thing I think to get him to plead guilty and
they put it out there and they said,
you know,
they were shaming him and making it this big deal.
This guy paid to get his dick touched,
you know?
And here he is.
What is he like 78 years old,
eight years old or something like that.
It's this old guy just wanting to get his dick touched.
He paid,
it was a deal's a deal.
She probably did it 13 times that day before him.
You know what I mean?
That's what they were doing in that place.
There were jerking guys off,
but people kept coming back.
Why they keep coming back because they hated it.
Why they keep coming back?
Because it was a rip off.
Why did they keep coming back?
No.
Because as adults they wanted to get their Dick touched and this woman was
willing to do that and she,
yeah.
Is that a bad job?
It's fucking terrible job.
So is Wendy's so as being a dishwasher,
those are terrible jobs to do.
You want to,
do you want to be the guy who puts the coal,
the fucking tar on the streets and the hot day?
Do you want to be that guy the fuck out of here?
That job sucks.
Do you want to be a guy who works in a a gas station?
We are constantly stiffened fumes.
Fuck that.
That job sucks.
Law Job Suck.
But it's your choice.
It's your choice as a human being to take that job or not take that job.
I fit.
Feel the same way about prostitution that I feel about massage.
It's like if you can pay someone to touch your feet and rub your feet,
you could pay a dude.
Just be rubbing your feet.
Why can't you pay someone to touch you?
Why can't we pay someone to touch your genitals?
Rid of the stigma by legalizing it and pretend those girls,
right?
I've been to the bunny ranch.
I got a tour,
I went,
you know,
my wife
gave you permission to call it a tour
and I had a map.
I had a fucking Hawaiian shirt on.
No,
I had the t shirt with the tour dates.
He died recently.
And it's often a soft diet.
Yeah.
So he invited me,
he came to a show I was doing in a Lake Tahoe,
I know Reno.
And he goes,
uh,
Hey,
do you want to come take a tour?
And like,
because of the stern connection,
I kind of knew him.
He says,
do you want to come take a tour of the ranch?
And I go,
let me call my wife.
And I called her and I go,
can I just,
I go,
I just want to see it,
just going to smell it.
And she goes,
well,
if you bring Kathleen role,
who is the feature act with you,
then you can go.
So they send a limo and we go off and we walk in and there was like one room had
like a fucking trap,
he's in it and the other one had a hot tub.
They all had different like themes to them and it was like,
it wasn't a Skanky as I thought,
but it was pretty down and dirty.
He was like trailers,
but they were clean.
And while I was there,
a doctor showed up and they gave them all fucking,
they checked their snatches for whatever they had a little kitchen at.
They'd somebody cooking little snacks for them.
They offered me some,
I said,
I'm going to pass.
And then a at the end he pulls me aside and he goes,
uh,
by the way,
Greg take any of the girls,
it's on the house.
And I go,
well then is,
I've never been with a prostitute before.
And it wasn't because of the hundred bucks.
I wasn't waiting for a Freebie.
And,
but the girls were,
they were happy.
They keep 50% of the money.
They can't use drugs on the premises.
They,
um,
they can refuse a customer and they come and go when they want.
I think people should be able to do whatever they want.
That doesn't hurt people.
I don't think that falls into that category.
And I think it does provide a service for really frustrated men that can't get
sex any other way.
Yeah,
and I think it's stigmatized.
I think it's stigmatized in a very weird way.
It's not a good job.
I don't want to do it.
I don't want my children to do it.
I don't want your children to do it.
I don't want my kids to work as a dishwasher either.
I don't want my kids to be a coal miner.
Those things are real jobs,
you know?
I just don't.
I think that if we had different attitudes about sex,
we wouldn't look at it as harshly.
We look at it as as horribly as we look at it.
We look at it different because we think they're like intimacies connected to
romance.
Romance is connected to this emotional connection you have with this person that
you're sharing pleasure with.
I'm like,
that's,
that is wonderful.
But physical release is also very important for men.
It's like it's very important.
It's very important for everyone to be touched and some people,
people don't want to touch them.
They're just not doing so good.
It's just that not in a good spot.
They don't,
they're not physically attractive,
whatever it is,
whatever the whatever.
For some people and they have a desire and a need to be touched and it fucking
wrecks them to the soul when they're not touched all the time.
They constantly walk around,
filled with resentment,
filled with bitterness.
We just quietly enraged inside at the the hand that life has given them.
And for those people,
if you had legalized prostitution,
if it was like someone who like you,
you could conceivably have friendships with these people that you're having sex
with if you wanted to do that.
Like I knew a girl who when she was younger,
she was a sex worker and she's a,
I don't want to even reveal her,
it'd be too obvious.
Five reveal what she does.
But she did it for a while when she was like young and she fucked some older
guys that were like,
you know,
in their sixties and shit and they didn't know,
they had money but they didn't have the time to date.
And you know,
maybe they had a wife and they wanted to have sex with somebody on the side and
she would take money from them and she liked it.
She's like,
it's a great way to make money.
It was a lot more money.
It's not that big a deal.
She was,
I knew who I was doing it with and I was like,
wow,
she's smart.
You know?
I mean,
I don't think everybody has that attitude and I would never want anybody to do
that.
That doesn't have that attitude.
But if you're one of those girls that's like hustling,
maybe you don't have a family that backs you up.
No.
These girls that like,
you know they're in there is legitimately like [inaudible].
I got a friend who's really wealthy and his friends have,
some of them have like a girl in New York and they pay for her apartment and
she's gone to college and he goes to New York seven,
eight times a year.
And when he does,
she frees her calendar and goes out to dinner with them,
goes to wherever he sleeps there.
They have sex and it's a comfortable working relationship,
so I don't know where's the,
where's the problem with that?
Who's the victim,
right?
Yeah,
he's a sugar daddy.
Yeah.
I don't,
I think we have crazy attitudes for finite beings.
We have this crazy idea to like,
we're leaving this permanent like ledger of all the moral and immoral things
we've done,
especially when it comes to sex.
It's just sex.
He fucks.
Yeah,
it's great.
Everybody wants it,
but everybody doesn't get it and sometimes people get rejected,
so carries all this weight and so it's just like a bit,
and then you're not supposed to do it because God doesn't want you to,
or you could get pregnant.
Jesus Christ.
Are you pro life?
Are you pro abortion?
He pro women's like to choose.
You didn't even,
you should even have a say.
You have a fucking penis.
They're like,
Whoa,
is this charge?
He is so charged and meanwhile biologically your brain is going,
no,
no.
We got him.
Fuck.
Okay.
I got loads building up.
I got to get rid of these things.
You know,
like I used to have a bit called jerk off first and think about it.
It was like my advice for everything because there's so many moments in life
where you jerk off first and then he'd go,
what?
What was I going to do?
Right.
I'm not calling her,
I'm definitely not respond to that crazy fucking letter.
She sat me in the mail.
You know when you get a letter from somebody like,
oh no,
it's like sell,
bring up jerk offers.
Jefferson know your real intentions.
If you jerk off first and you still want to call someone,
you really care about them.
You love them.
That's right.
It's not just lust.
That's it.
That's empty bag.
Thank Ya.
Yeah.
I,
I was never good at that.
Like A,
I've,
I reset the clock one nowadays.
I pop give me 24 hours to leave me alone.
25 24 hours.
Well,
I think I need some of those pills.
He said testosterone.
Yeah.
Need some tea.
Our tea is that,
is that legal?
Oh,
100% yeah.
I think I need somebody I need to do medically to some of that.
Yeah,
dude,
I've been on that show for 10 years.
No Shit.
Yeah.
And you make it a bunch of different ways now to theirs.
They were making the spray for awhile.
It goes under the tongue.
You could put drops in and then,
I don't know if they're doing that anymore,
but they have a cream.
The cream is good,
but if you hug people that gets on them.
It's weird.
Wait,
where do you rub it on?
You rub it over your chest or your arms.
So if you have sex with your wife,
your wife started Mike growing a mustache.
We've you fucking very strange.
That'd be at like a really creepy way if you were like really in a dude's,
but you were married to a woman or how do I,
how do I bridge this gap?
Right?
Like I'm on TRT and you would rub it all over your chest and immediately get on
her and she believed the fuck are you doing?
Give her protein shakes.
Make her go to the gym a lot.
Yeah.
Hey honey,
you look good with short hair.
Put her under stress to make her work more.
That's something happens with women.
Apparently there was a study on a career women,
and they don't know if it's a correlation or causation thing because maybe the
reason why they were queer career women and the first place,
because they had a lot of testosterone,
but they were,
they would notice that women,
you have to fend for themselves.
Women have to take care of themselves.
They,
they,
they generally have more testosterone.
Interesting.
Which makes sense,
but it doesn't,
I,
you never know like what came first,
the chicken or the egg,
is that like who they are or are they developing more testosterone because
they're,
they have to be out there competing.
Yeah.
You know?
I remember I was,
uh,
I used Rogaine for awhile.
I was actually,
I got approached by my agent and he goes,
um,
you've got an offer to do a commercial,
a series of commercials.
I said,
for what?
And he goes,
Rogaine,
I go,
but I do,
my hair is not thinning.
And he's like,
yeah,
so a,
it's five commercials.
I was in denial about it.
I was like 29 and I guess I was starting to crown a little bit,
but I didn't notice.
And so he goes,
do you want to do it?
And I was like,
ah,
I don't know.
Um,
and about to move out to la,
I want to maybe do some acting.
I don't want to be seen maybe on TV as the road gang gang.
He's like,
I talked to them and they said it's only good or it's going to be on like ESPN
for at two in the morning.
Don't worry about it.
And I go and I go,
all right,
fuck it.
I'm moving to La.
I got no money.
I'll do it.
I'll get health insurance out of it.
I'm about to get married.
So I record the commercials and the tagline is it's me and a pharmacy and I'm
looking at a bottle and it's Madonna monoxide,
il five they just jacked it up from three to five and I go a four out of five.
The Voice of our goes,
four out of five doctors say this'll work.
And then I go,
I look at the camera and I go,
four out of five.
I like my chances.
Oh Geez.
So there you are.
So I know.
So I do it,
I do it.
And then,
uh,
there is,
there's that guy,
oh look,
the nod.
You're like,
yeah,
this is legit.
So they,
uh,
so all of a sudden it starts running.
It runs during the fucking playoffs.
March madness.
Every guy I've ever met was calling me and gone.
I like my,
I'm walking down the street.
I like Mike Jensen.
It was everywhere.
Yeah.
And so they gave me,
they gave me a fucking supply for years and I was using it and I would,
my wife wouldn't let me cuddle with her because she don't,
you put on your head at the end of the day before you go to bed and cuddle up
next to her and get chicken fucking hair on her neck and it made you all greasy.
My pillows were all greasy and all it really grew was like a,
like a fuzz.
Did you ever try that shit?
I
tried that shit.
I tried everything.
Yeah.
I wish I had shaved my head way earlier.
It's so easy.
I think I'm going to do it tomorrow.
For the first time in my life,
once I shaved my head,
I was like,
why am I fucking around with all this hair?
Yeah.
If I had a full head of hair,
I shaved my fucking head.
I shaved my head like every two weeks.
I would just let grow to stubble.
Then shave it down again.
Let it grow to stubble.
It's like it's so much easier.
How often do you shave it?
Every couple of days.
You take a razor [inaudible] the buzzer?
Yeah.
Easy.
I have one that has like a,
it's made for shaving your head.
It's got like a handle on it.
It's like an electric razor.
Just wow.
Rant.
Rant,
rant,
rant.
So you don't miss any spots.
How long does it take?
A couple minutes.
Let's you feel good?
Yeah,
that's great.
I don't have to think about it.
That's what I like.
I don't know this.
I don't think about this.
I used to worry about my hair when my hair was falling out.
When something's out of your control for people to have a full head of hair.
They really don't understand this.
When you start losing your hair,
Young Jami,
son of a bitch,
when you start losing your hair,
you,
you just go,
oh my God.
Like this is nothing I can do about this.
This is terrible.
Like there's nothing you can do.
And then you look at it like these fucking guys,
like some guys that are like gross looking bald dudes and he like,
oh my God,
they used to be a kid.
They used to be just like me and then one day it all fucking fell out and they
were this gross dude with the horseshoe around the bottom of the head.
Like what the fuck?
That's what I'm going to be.
And once he shaved your head,
like for me,
I got lucky.
I have a good shape in good shape ahead,
which is something that I watched.
I went down a rabbit hole the other day and uh,
I went down a plastic surgery,
facial reconnect,
reconstruct configuration rabbit hole because of in cells connected to this
conversation we were having earlier about guys can't get laid.
Yeah,
these guys were going to,
this one doctor,
there's a particular doctor,
I think he's in Indianapolis and he does a facial reconfiguration.
Likehey widens your jaw.
He puts implants on your cheeks and jaw.
He puts implants on your fucking head.
So I get,
maybe you have a weird shape,
ted.
Maybe your head is shaped like a turtle or something.
They have a weird crest in the top of your head.
This guy puts implants under your skin to give you a nice round head.
And they had like before and after and this guy was like,
oh,
he's hated my head.
Now my head's amazing and I'm looking at this and I'm going,
oh my God.
Like I didn't even think of that.
But it look,
it looked way better.
Yeah.
But it's,
what it is is like genetics or responding to symmetry.
When you see,
when you see poor genetics,
you see something weird like weird symmetry.
Why is this,
why is this face so narrow?
Why is this chin go down so low?
What's weird about him?
Why is or why his shoulder,
so narrow wires arm so long.
When you see asymmetrical or weird looking people that don't seem to like,
it doesn't fit into your idea of what the accepted breeding genetics of human
beings are eventually comes.
Yeah.
Is that what it is?
It's based on a,
there's a,
there's a certain shape of the face and the FIBONACCI FIBONACCI code.
Is that what you're thinking?
No,
no.
I think it's the Davinci could if there was a religious thing for that movie.
Yeah.
But with within it,
don't they talk about the symmetry of the face?
I think that's the golden ratio.
Yeah.
That's the FIBONACCI.
The FIBONACCI code.
But yeah,
this is the guy.
This is sky.
Wow.
So they uh,
oh,
this is an article from cut the cut the cut.com.
Yeah,
that's,
this is exactly where I started.
So I started on this and um,
I think it was on date or something like that.
And then I went from that to all of the,
uh,
different people that have these things done.
And that's something if you think about it,
man,
if you just get a bum deal,
you just get a bit a bad roll.
The dice,
you will live your life with people that don't,
they don't want to have sex with you.
And this goes back to like the prostitution thing.
Like what do people want from those people?
Do they want the world to be a different place than it really is?
Cause are we operating as if this world is exactly how it is right now?
Or are we pretending that the world is how we'd like it to be one day in a
Utopian society?
Because if we're doing that,
I get how you're behaving.
But if you're looking at the world around you the way it is and you don't think
these guys should be able to get prostitutes,
you're,
you're an asshole.
I think that kind of boils down with libertarianism is,
you know,
it's whether or not we are in a evolving you utopian mindset or whether or not
we're going to just say,
let people be who they are and just accept how things are.
Does a little bit of that.
I think I'm on both sides of that fence sometimes.
You know,
there's,
there's definitely people that you just want to leave him alone,
like they're not going to figure it out.
Fuck them.
But then there's also people,
like,
we've all met people that have been in a bad place in their life and turned it
around.
I don't,
I don't like giving up on people.
I just don't,
it's not human.
It's not a human thing.
Just give up on people.
Right.
So
I,
I've,
I'm on both sides of that.
Like,
part of me wants to go look,
figured out,
and then part of me wants to go,
like,
we got to help people figure it out.
Yeah.
And we have to try to engineer our society.
Like this is a problem.
It's like we were talking about before about reparations for slavery or these,
uh,
these communities that have always been black and poor since the slave times.
Like to just leave that alone and let that sort itself out that has never gonna
sort itself out.
That's like a place in your garage that's fucked up and filled with trash that
you think is going to figure itself out on its own.
Like you,
you,
you got to do something.
The garbage that you're leaving behind,
that's not gonna make its way to the trash.
You're going to have to sort it out.
You didn't have to figure out how to do it.
You have to get it out there.
If you have a impoverished crime riddled community filled with drugs and gangs,
it's not going to get better.
You have to do something.
Somebody has to do something.
You can't just pretend.
You can't just go further and further away from it.
If we're going to act as a country and it's what we're supposed to be,
we're supposed to be a big ass team.
We were supposed to be looking at the spots on the team that are fucked up.
Yeah.
You talk about that.
Houston is kind of famous for this.
Literally the garbage dumps we're all put in the black
neighborhoods.
They just started dumping all the garbage in the poor areas with the bad
schools.
Totally segregated and it's the same areas that were,
they were slave shacks way back when and now it's the same fucking generations
later living in garbage.
All right,
and it has to be the,
because we have to do a DNA test.
Find out your great grandfather was the guy who put the fucking garbage dump in
the black neighborhood and that's what you have a catalog dude.
My Wallet's on the table at that point.
Take it off.
I'm so sorry,
but you didn't do anything.
You're 23 I recycle now.
Thank you.
But Steph,
in the green bins,
the blue bins,
you're going to save those fish compost bins.
Those whales out there.
It's eating plastic.
Yeah.
We gotta just,
we get a genetic engineer,
the whales to actually be able to digest plastic.
Figure it out.
We're good.
It's free food.
Yeah.
Come on,
man.
We got boy on slot on the podcast and he's just really young genius who is in
the middle of devising and implementing a way to gather up the plastic.
He's got like this big machine that operates,
oh,
I saw this guy,
big arm on it.
It's like,
yeah,
it's like gotta look on net capturing.
I'm,
I'm really breaking it down much like a paraphrasing in a shitty way,
but his machine is just going to scoop plastic up and they think they're good.
Actually reuse that plastic and make things out of it.
Yeah,
I saw that.
I think they,
I think they ran into some technical problems with it.
They just used it.
Yeah.
I think the,
when they tried it out right away,
it didn't work that good.
Yeah,
but he kind of figured that.
He was like,
well,
there's going to be a bunch of improvements.
It's like everything else.
Everything go by early Tesla.
They were terrible.
Maybe over Tesla May,
may not last.
Really?
Yeah.
They're saying that.
Well,
the problem is is they,
they call it the entrepreneurial Shiny Object Syndrome.
That's what Ilan Musk has his like he can't stop.
He has to keep,
you know,
there was space acts which is fucking phenomenal,
right?
What that program has done,
they are,
they are delivering a stuff to space for a 10th of the price of NASA.
They have cut costs ridiculously.
NASA was so fucking bloated and,
and which was great,
but now it's like he wants to put a fucking tunnel under la and he wants these
charging stations all around the country that are going to be solar powered,
that are going to be expensive.
He's just overextended himself and now Wall Street used to love them and now
they're not buying it anymore.
And it could be the end of the company.
How would it be the end of the company?
How's that work?
Well,
there the um,
they need to be producing like a million cars a year to be cost effective for
their,
um,
assembly lines for the,
it costs for their assembly lines and they're putting out a few hundred thousand
a year and they need to,
they need to up production to that point.
And they don't think they can do it.
I shouldn't say that.
I'm going to fucking tank the stock.
Yeah.
It's um,
how many different places can you charge out now?
I always charge here or a charge at home.
Yeah.
But how many places it real easy to charge.
Can you find a lot of spots?
I have no idea,
but I know he's trying to make it really universal.
It's great if you drive and it just to work like I do,
I drive it to the store or dry wood here.
It's great.
Yeah,
they're the,
it's the best car I've ever driven but,
but it's not,
it's not ready for like long ass trips takes 10 hours time.
My friend just bought a,
I think it's a Mitsubishi and it's um,
it's a hybrid,
but how it works is it goes all electric until you run out of the electric
charge.
And then it had done the motor kicks San as opposed to that.
Like my,
my Prius,
which is just all chatting back and forth all the time.
Right.
The Prius gets ridiculous gas models though.
It's amazing.
What do you get?
Probably 50 wow.
That's hilarious.
It looks like dog shit though.
I hate it.
Why do you,
why do you deal with it?
Why do you do that yourself?
You and I have had this conversation a million times.
I'm like,
Greg,
get a muscle car.
I want a Mustang.
All I want.
The new ones are amazing and matter of fact,
they have a new bullet Mustang now that they do.
Is they do?
Yes they do.
They have a bullet model,
brand new 2019 green,
Emerald Green Dope ass fucking Mustang with a,
I think it's more than 460 horsepower.
It's a very fast,
it's an up tuned version of the one that's in the GT.
So it's there.
Coyote generation three Mustang engine.
Look at that.
That's it.
Bay Be.
Oh my God,
I see it even says boat on the back.
See the back,
the back badge.
That's a bullet Mustang.
That's the yellow thousand 19 and you get into stick shift like a fucking man.
Fat.
Yeah,
I definitely got to get a stick shift drive around your,
your,
your balls are going to grow back.
I need them back.
I need the A,
it's a beautiful car.
I need this Tiara.
TRT is that the testosterone therapy needed another prints in your life.
Praise is like shut your mouth at that Prius and stop talking about it.
Look at that Mustang bullet 2019.
It's like,
you know the 50th anniversary of the movie or whatever the hell it is.
Yeah.
When was that movie?
40th 68 so yeah,
more than 50th.
Look at that man.
Whew.
Damn.
That's a car and it's a motherfucker of a car.
They,
they make great American cars right now.
Right now's a great time.
You know the two of them,
the old one,
the new one will allow,
can you know the great thing is,
is the gas mileage on these cars isn't that bad anymore?
Yeah.
The,
they have intelligent computers running all of the,
uh,
fuel injection and everything and it was the tune of the engines all done with
computers.
Now can I get one pro?
Come on.
Stop fucking around.
Yeah.
What are we going to get younger?
We're not,
you know,
it is,
it's the whole college thing.
But like fuck up near a talented comedian,
nick.
Plenty of loot.
You're going to have spend money on the stupid Prius.
That thing is not free.
You have to pay for that thing.
Yeah.
Kidding.
God Damn Mustang.
How much one of those bullet mustangs trying to sell it.
Jamie,
why you think it's funny?
You know him,
right?
Right.
I know you're right.
To how much is that the end of my life?
I'm no,
no,
no.
Now if it's in one of my kids now I'm saying at the end of my life when I look
back,
I'm going to go,
oh my kid went to college.
Fuck him.
He can take a loan.
Do you have the room for it in your driveway?
If you had a third car?
Uh,
we parked on the street.
I live in Venice.
46,000.
That's not much buddy.
That's a good deal.
Get that fucking thing.
He parked in the street set like a Kickstarter fund or something from my car.
I think people would do that.
Um,
no.
They would say just do some gigs and put some money away.
You son of a bitch.
I know you fucking,
yeah,
sell out places.
Shut the fuck up some dudes you just so frugal.
I always find that so funny cause I'm such a slob
but that's how we were when we started in Boston.
Oh you were driving a fucking suicide,
a Celica gt or something that you are,
it was a Mitsubishi story on,
it's like a little sporty liquor.
Yeah and you were leasing it and I was like who the fuck leases a new car when
they've been doing comedy for two years and I had a fucking,
I had an 84 Volkswagen rabbit and and I just remember he had a fucking nice were
had a jacked up stereo system in it and I remember you got it got fucking
repossessed though.
That was a different card.
That was the dodge Daytona Shelby.
I got rid of the one that I got the second one.
And you didn't give a fuck or you went to the,
you went to the impound lot and you jumped the fence to get the radio out.
Right.
I had a stereo I put in it.
I installed the stereo,
I jumped the fence and pulled the fucking stereo out of the Daytona
because I knew I wasn't going to be able to pay for that fucking car anymore
cause it was okay.
It was actually,
that was the first year of comedy.
That was my first year.
I actually got that while I was still teaching and I was still,
um,
I taught,
I was teaching at Boston University.
I was teaching taekwondo there.
I was teaching at this school that I was running and revere and I was delivering
newspapers.
So I was making a little bit of money and I was really stupid.
And when I found out that I could get a car,
like a brand new dodge Daytona Shelby in 1988 or 1989 and uh,
I could,
I could lease it,
they would lease it to me,
is what I was like,
perfect,
let's do it.
But then somewhere along the line I had decided I was really going to dedicate
myself to stand up.
I was like,
I am,
I'm half asking this.
And some of the told me that one of the guys that I was doing open mic nights,
he said,
you know,
you were really funny and like six months ago,
but,
but he goes,
but it seems like you've fallen off a little.
And he said it to me and I didn't even respond.
I remember like,
fuck,
he's right.
He's right.
I'm half ass in it.
And then that night I was like,
fuck this,
I'm quitting everything.
So I decided I was going to quit teaching.
I quit at Bu,
I quit teaching,
I school,
I shut my school down.
I was like,
I'm done.
I gotta,
I gotta be a comic 100% and then I had no money.
So you just said,
so I lost the golf,
whatever.
I make them stand up at that.
I was trying to get
odd jobs during the day.
Yeah.
But I couldn't have anything that I was dedicated to.
And when I was teaching,
I was very dedicated to teaching t it meant a lot to me.
Like martial arts meant a lot to me.
So I'm technique means a lot to me.
So when I was teaching people,
it's very specific,
like admit a lot.
Yeah.
And I would teach people how to bring them to tournaments and you know,
I'd raised kids from like white belt all the way up to like blue belt and
brought him to tournaments and it was exciting.
It was really fun.
It meant a lot to me though.
It meant enough to me that I was not going to half ass it.
I was like,
I'm not gonna,
I'm not gonna have teach these people.
Cause when I was teaching I was very serious about it and meant a lot.
So I was like,
I'm not,
I got a,
I'm a,
I'm a coach.
Once I have a thing,
I'm like,
that's the thing.
All these other things just get in the way of the thing.
I have to just eliminate those.
And so that's what I did.
And then they took my fucking car,
but I got the stereo.
Yeah.
He's like that.
I remember because,
uh,
I was,
I was living with your girlfriend and you were coming over and night.
Fucking,
you'd come from like Cappuccinos,
the restaurant around the corner with fucking take out like nice meals.
I was eating fucking ramen noodles.
Spent every penny.
I spent everything.
I didn't put anything away.
Ever come from blockbuster with fucking five movies under your arm.
Yeah.
You were living with my girlfriend and another dude guy,
gay guy named Mike Mike Coconut,
who's a great guy.
He was a great dude.
He was the first guy I ever met who had a flux.
Oh,
no shit.
Yeah.
He was the first guy I met who was growing marijuana in his closet.
Oh Shit.
Lights.
That's dangerous in Boston,
the 80s right.
You'd go to jail.
Jail.
He grow.
He,
that was some skunk weed.
We sit around smoking that Skunk Weed Gel Gel
for that.
Yeah.
Massachusetts 100% free now.
Hundred percent legal.
Go to a store and buy it.
Yeah.
How fucking beautiful is that?
Illinois House passes marijuana legalization.
Oh Wow.
Yes.
Two Pritzker.
I'm hoping that a governor to fuck.
Yeah,
fuck yeah.
Legalize Illinois and get a gang of it out to the south side of Chicago.
Speaking of disenfranchised neighborhoods that are not going to fix themselves.
That's another one.
There was five murders there last week.
It's crazy.
And the schools are so fucking bad.
There was this really good documentary called America is me and attracts a oak
park,
which is like a kind of a mixed suburb in Chicago where this black and white
students and they just track the lives of like 10 students and hit five black
and five white and how they can be in the same place and have such different
experiences.
You know,
black families where the fucking kid is stressed out.
He's doing well in school and they're like,
the teacher's frustrated,
but he's like,
yeah,
his,
he's got a single mom and they just lost the apartment because she lost her job
and now they're living with an aunt and you know,
there's all these circumstances going on.
And then you've got the white kids who are taking sat prep classes and they got
a mom who's not working that drives them to their different sports.
Um,
it's a,
it's a great documentary.
It's a different world.
That's,
I mean,
this is the same conversation we were having before the podcast started about
this guy that we know that things that homeless people are lazy.
Yeah.
And we were like,
look,
there are people out there that were born on third base and they fucking swear
to God,
they hit a triple and they think,
Whoa,
I fucking didn't have my shoes tied and I didn't do this and I missed out on
birthday parties and I,
but nobody shot you.
Yeah.
You know,
nobody robbed you.
Your,
your aunt,
uncle didn't rape you in jail.
You didn't,
you didn't watch your brother getting killed.
You know,
like,
oh come on man.
Like there's way worse hands that people get dealt way worse.
And just the overall vague sense of entitlement.
Well,
am I saying on the other side of being surrounded by people that are not
achieving and being,
being exposed to people that don't think that finishing high school or college
is a priority.
And so it's very hard to come up with that concept yourself.
Especially in the absence of like two functioning parents.
The only thing that helps them now is the internet,
because you can,
you could lock onto like David Goggins or someone like that or someone who was
also born into this terrible situations like that.
And you can listen to his story and read his or listen to the audio book,
which is fantastic.
Read as a book and understand there's people like him that used to be like me,
they made it through and now they have a story and I can do that too.
It's possible.
And then that becomes your guiding light.
But the idea that we're all on the same fucking starting block,
it's just stupid as fuck.
Yeah,
it's stupid.
It's stupid.
It's a bad way to look at the world.
And when people get upset at,
you know,
certain aspects of life without acknowledging that.
Yeah.
And then you've got people that live in abandoned factory towns,
whether it's,
you know,
in the Appalachias or it's in,
Detroit where you had jobs and your grandfather had a job and that was it.
And it was just a,
it was like there was no diversity of work in that area.
And then the fucking plant closes and it's just despair.
I have a
good friend and his family is from coal miners and uh,
I mean he,
the way he describes it,
he's like,
you have never seen that kind of poverty before.
You've never seen that kind of poverty when you're in these coal towns.
And people just all fucked up on pills.
Like the whole town's fucked up on pills.
I was like,
you haven't seen poverty like that.
It's dark.
And then there's despair and there's no exit strategy.
No one,
there's no one to model around you.
no one's there to give you advise.
Everyone's a criminal.
Everyone's trying to get by everyone's selling pills,
robbing people,
shooting people.
And this is just a segment.
This is just what happens with despair.
Right?
And this is just despair in that,
in that context.
Then,
then there's despair in south central La.
Just despair in east la does despair and you know,
really fucked up Mexican neighborhoods in La.
Well,
that's why we were talking about,
I think you had a guest on that,
talked about how with how everything's getting ro robots are taking over.
That's the book by and Yang.
It was probably the presidential candidate talking about how they're going to
subsidize the,
uh,
the,
the whole populations.
Yes.
He's probably universal basic income with that,
you know,
it sounds like it may happen that that type of a system,
but there's still going to be despair because you still need a sense of purpose.
You still need to work and feel good about yourself.
That's the counter to that.
Yeah,
and I agree with both things.
Unfortunately.
It's like I agree that most likely automation is going to take over.
Here's the thing,
when,
when people need purpose,
they still need purpose.
They need purpose now,
but would $1,000 a month if everyone knew they had $1,000 a month coming from
the government,
would it make you more invested in being an American?
Would it make you more invested in keeping this thing running?
Like you're,
you're actually getting paid from it.
You're looking at America like it's generating income.
And you're getting paid from it.
You're getting enough money so you can eat and have a roof over your head.
Like if the three of us got $1,000 a month,
that's $3,000 a month.
There's a place we could get with the three of us.
It was like 1500 bucks a month and then the rest of it we would just put into
food and whatever,
and that's,
we could live hookers.
You would live like that.
That's a,
that's a livable wage for enough if you get enough people to get $1,000 a month.
So the question is how does it make you feel about yourself and about your
country?
But the,
yeah,
and this is the question too,
does that stop you from pursuing your dreams?
Because it's not like you're getting 50 grand a year.
Like if you were getting 50 grand a year,
like man,
be hard to get me to work if I just had free 50 grand every year.
Like how much do you do you really need,
if you have an apartment,
like it's not easy.
I know folks that are making 50 grand,
I'm like,
Hey,
you know,
you'd be surprised.
You don't really save much.
And you know,
once you,
if you have a car and a lease and a either a mortgage or an apartment payment,
I get it,
I get it.
But if you had 50 grand a year,
it'd be really hard for you to grind.
It'd be really hard for you to really go after something.
Just be obsessed.
Unless that's just your style,
that's just who you are.
Well,
it seems like,
um,
I dunno if it's more manageable way is just socialize medicine and make higher
education Frey.
I think both those things are imperative.
I really do.
I think especially education.
Why would it cost?
Why should it cost money to figure out how to make people more intelligent and
contribute better?
Why wouldn't you want less losers when you want more educated people that have a
better understanding of how the world works?
Especially since we're a service economy,
we're not a manufacturing economy anymore.
We need people that understand how to manage and to be entrepreneurial and you
know,
yes.
Communicate well.
Just be educated.
I mean,
if there's more people that are smarter than you,
have more competition than you have more productivity.
They mean it would just be better for everybody.
You don't want ignorant people.
Yeah.
Want education?
My son's going to college.
It's fucking $65,000 a year.
That's so much times four years time.
So kids that $600,000 a year,
what?
American's got an extra six.
So your kid is now saddled with a debt that he'll be paying off forever.
He's underwater.
$600,000 a year.
You're saying $65,000 a year in two kids be five 70 180,000 you mean 60 you mean
forever?
Yeah,
for four years.
For four years time.
Two kids like 650 grand a year.
I was like 600 total over over the course of their college careers.
Yeah.
Your base.
And you have to make more than a million to have that by the way.
Yeah.
Cause you gotta pay taxes.
And you're not just only spending money on that.
You've got to spend money on living expenses and your mortgage and your house so
that you know you're really talking about 2 million probably
and and don't think your kids coming out of college into a job that's going to
be able to support himself.
You're still going to be subsidizing their phone in their car insurance and
probably part of their rent for the next five,
six years after that
they come to visit.
Yeah,
and if you're thinking about that over over these four years that you really,
if you want a hundred grand you kind of have to make 200
and then you got insurance.
If you're on the market as a family of four to get health insurance in
California,
you're paying $20,000 a year between 15 and $20,000 a year,
which means again you got to earn 40
a lot of people are moving out of California because of state tax.
A lot of people realize,
you know,
I can live in Nevada and not pay any state tax.
Yeah.
Why would I want to pay state docs?
What am I doing?
That's a lot of money.
It is like a 10% right.
Yeah.
And then if you live in New York City,
you have to pay a stain in a city tax.
Oh,
you dirty bitch fat fucking city tax is that to keep the rats,
that's to keep the electricity going for the guys that are taking the train in
from Connecticut every day and working on Wall Street that aren't paying the
fucking city tax
fucking communists.
Yeah.
The people don't pay the city tax or dirty yup.
To work in the city and they don't pay the tax.
Right.
Most pay the tax those uh,
states in Connecticut.
Yeah.
Those Weird Solis.
Gigantic,
great Gatsby like estates,
Darien,
Connecticut,
and they've all got fucking Ferrari's.
A buddy my watch on ice transmissions buddy might work.
So high school in Connecticut where all these rich kids go to school.
He works there.
Shout out to my boy Tommy Jr.
Yeah.
He works there and sees these people,
these giant fucking huge lawns and talking about buying a place there.
I want a big line.
I want to be
Kennedy.
I'd like to live next to a bunch of people that are on pills out of her fucking
mind.
Trying to make meaning out of life.
$3 billion in the bank.
I want people whose heads had been reshaped by a guy in Indianapolis.
Yeah.
If you have a flat head though,
there's some girls don't want to fuck a dude with the flow.
I'm going to shave my head,
but it's not going to let us fly.
I get a bad head.
You're fine.
I'm to turn sideways.
Pasty white dude.
Shave your failure.
Yeah.
We'll show you what it tomorrow.
Do we have the clippers from the town board right now?
Do we really?
Are they over there?
Have they charged up?
Probably.
If it only went halfway and then cut off,
you should have that.
That should be your new look like criss cross one of these to have their clothes
on backwards.
He shaved half the side of your head,
shaved one side and leave the other side and people like what is going on?
You're like,
fuck you.
I'm handicap.
Look at my head.
Yeah.
Half the crowd.
I'm doing bald jokes for half the crowd.
The other half.
Are you doing like going bald jokes?
Dude,
I had Ari Shaffir on my podcast one time and uh,
we were at you ever,
you ever do a podcast and the above the comedy cellar,
they've got a studio up,
dammit.
Bobby Kelly started it and it's a,
I forget what it's called.
And um,
so I'm up there doing my podcast with Ari and it's an apartment.
It's like,
does a,
does a bedroom and a bathroom and in the studio.
And we got to talking about torture.
And I go,
uh,
I go,
you ever been waterboarded?
He's like,
no,
I go,
this is a bathroom right here I go,
you want to,
you want me to waterboard you and you know Ari's like,
Yep,
sure,
let's do it.
So we go inside and I put a towel over his face and he leans over backwards and
his head is below his body in the shower stall.
The nozzle comes off the wall and I spray down his face and uh,
nothing,
nothing.
And then all of a sudden his bodies convulsing,
his legs are kicking,
he's fucking screaming,
water is shooting out of his nose.
He's choking and it went on for like a couple of minutes and I'm fucking dying.
And then he starts laughing and we were just on the podcast laughing without
saying a word for probably five minutes.
And then he goes,
well I'm going to do it to you.
I'm like,
fuck yeah.
He waterboarded me in the same thing happened.
Wow.
Yeah.
Waterboarding's legit.
Yeah,
yeah.
You can't,
that's real torture.
Yeah.
But it's weird torture cause you're not permanently injuring someone.
Like can you think of towards,
you think of like someone cutting someone,
lighting them on fire,
Shit like that.
What's the torture you would least want to be done to you?
That's a good question.
Maybe that one.
Maybe waterboarding.
I Dunno.
I got like electrocution.
They electrocute you.
Ozarks.
Spoiler alert.
Oh yeah.
Don't say nothing.
Yeah.
I think,
I think being made to be cold
for long periods,
I'm cold and knows.
They say no sleep is actually the worst thing you can
do to somebody's Chinese water torture.
They just have the water drip on you.
Yeah.
Just keeps you awake.
Trip days trip.
Yeah.
That's a good tip.
If you ever fallen asleep while you're driving folks,
get a,
if you stop at a gas station and get like a soda or a water and some ice and
then get like wet towel,
get a wet towel with ice in it and just rub your face.
Cause I used to smack myself in the face when I was coming back from gigs.
Yeah.
And I'd be driving on the mass pike and a smack in the face.
Just sticking my head out the window.
You know,
just trying to stay away because you're,
you just something about the hypnotic white lines.
Just dude,
I used to fucking locked on.
I used to drive from Boston to New York like once a week for like a year and a
half.
I had a,
I had a place I could crash in the city and I'd finished my gigs on Saturday
night.
I'd be at the fucking Worcester Heloc,
the show.
It ended like,
you know,
midnight and I'd get my car and I'd drive the three,
three and a half hours to the city and I regularly slept while driving and then
snapped out of it.
Like how fucking crazy is that?
I once wrecked the car,
I fell asleep on the,
on the highway once I will you,
I was in college and uh,
I had to go down to providence for a court date.
I got into a fight in providence and I got arrested,
spent the weekend in jail and I had to come back for the court appearance.
So I borrowed my ex girlfriend's car and I'd been up the night before,
all night drinking.
And so I drove down and uh,
I did the court appearance,
got out of it and I'm driving home and I'm on 95 north and
I just fucking fell asleep and I hit the guardrail,
spun out and hit a truck.
Oh my God.
And thank God I got,
um,
I cut my mouth.
I hit my mouth on the steering wheel.
This is why we,
no airbags,
no,
it was old Toyota Corolla.
Fucking total.
The car.
Oh,
my ex girlfriend's car.
Oh No.
Yeah.
Oh,
she feel she was all right with it.
She was all right with it.
She's alive.
She was a great girl.
Oh yeah.
Cindy Murtha shout out to Cindy.
So you probably were relieved because of the court date,
right?
Yeah.
You relieved.
Oh,
got off.
Can't believe he got off.
Right.
And then drive them back.
Bang.
Fuck.
What a feeling,
man.
You talk about adrenaline rushing into your body that second.
It can't get no more intense than that.
Cause I knew from high school died that way.
Oh No.
Shit really hit like the underside of the bridge.
Damn.
If he was asleep or he was drinking asleep,
fell asleep.
Damn.
Yeah.
Happens all the time,
man.
My father,
he was a,
my father was a big drinker and he was driving home drunk one time and uh,
my mom was following him and another car,
that's how complicit alcoholism was back in the 70s wives were just like,
all right honey,
I'll follow you because you're drunk.
Oh my God.
And so he's driving and he falls asleep at the wheel and he goes head first into
a tree.
Oh,
Jesus cuts his jugular vein and his arm,
the veins in his arm.
My mom drives to get an ambulance.
Know there's no cell phones.
They come by the time they get there,
he has no vital signs.
He's fucking dead.
And they brought him back to life and he was in the hospital for like two weeks.
Whoa.
Are they bringing back to life?
I have no fucking idea.
I was like,
I was like five.
I was like four or five and what does that,
they have some stuff.
They set us up.
Yeah.
They really look your guy here,
right?
Pet cemetery injection.
Bring it back.
That's right.
Bring 'em back.
Spike and I didn't see the new pet cemetery.
I heard it was a,
yeah.
Who was that based on the Stephen King Book.
Yeah,
the book is Great.
the movie,
the first movie was all right.
Who's all right?
They're fun.
They're there.
Campy.
The difference between his books in his movies though are so profound because
books are terrifying.
Is books like get to the heart of the worst aspects of human nature and right.
Demonic possession to want maximum overdrive would be a great one to remake.
Now fucking robots are and yeah.
Shame takes over and kills everyone.
Yeah.
No Shit.
Right?
Yeah.
They have it like with modern electric trucks and shit.
The shining was the only one that was as scary as the book.
What was different?
Very different than the book does the show,
was it?
Yeah.
I read the book,
the,
the Shining,
the movie with Jack Nicholson apparently bothered Stephen King because Jack
Nicholson was like on edge from the beginning of the movie.
Like he was always crazy.
Like,
he was always like,
you know,
he's always just kind of barely fucking hanging on.
Yeah.
You know,
that was his whole thing.
Right.
In the book.
The guy clearly becomes mad.
He becomes possessed.
He's a normal guy who's just struggling and trying to be a writer and he uses
this as an opportunity to write and then the house takes them over.
Right.
It's more sort of an arc.
Yeah.
It's,
well,
this is nothing you can do.
I Tim getting pumped up for the scene.
Oh yeah.
Didn't fire it up.
Look at them.
Yeah.
Is that Kubrick?
Yeah,
yeah.
Cute.
He doesn't want you to killed by a fucking axe.
Axe Willing Jack next.
Hold on.
Yeah,
I could see that once Kubrick takes over a year.
Now you're not going to have a lot of say in how the thing is direct.
Well not only that,
Kubrick put all this moon landing stuff in it.
There was all these moon references.
Yeah.
The kid had an Apollo sweater on like there was,
there's,
there's someone made a documentary that was all the numbers and all the co,
all the things that are attached to that movie room to 37.
That's what it's about because it's 237,000 miles to the moon when they uh,
made the launch,
sees,
got USA Apollo sweater on the little boy he did.
There's a bunch of things.
Yeah,
there's a ton of things that Kubrick did on purpose cause he would put weird
stuff like that in his movies.
He's a fascinating guy,
man.
Do you know he was like a high level math petition.
No,
Shit.
Yeah.
He would do high level mathematics for fun while he wasn't doing movies.
Wow.
Yeah.
They had an exhibit at Lacma in La ever that Stanley Kubrick exhibit for like
six months.
It was fucking wild.
That plays should be flattened.
They should take all the homeless people and move them there.
That places the most,
the biggest abomination of all of Los Angeles.
I went there.
There's a clear plastic box that was a,
yeah,
like this boxes are hurt.
It's like,
this is art.
This is art.
It's our space and me,
this box and this is our art.
Like what?
Like do they have it roped off so you don't sit on the box?
It's like a plexiglass box.
Like get the fuck out of my face with this.
You know what you're doing.
Another piece of art was like people throwing basketballs in the net.
There was like like videos of basketballs like over and over and over again to
throwing basketballs.
I'm like,
Hey,
hey,
fuck you.
Fuck you.
I know what you're doing.
Yeah,
You don't,
this isn't art.
You know,
this is not art.
and there was some art there when there was some of that stuff.
There's some things you're like,
hey,
fuck you with this box.
I know what you're doing and you get paid for this.
Who's paying you?
Is this tax payer funded,
isn't it?
There's the LACMA.
Yes.
Yeah.
They probably have to pay the people to rent their art burrow.
The fucking real estate they're living in.
Yeah.
I heard something recently about museum.
Is that only something like 7% like most collections or what you see there's so
much stuff in storage like cool shit that people might want to see that there's
not room for because the buildings aren't big enough.
Really good.
Lots of instruments.
For instance,
300 year old violins get used by like kids because it's a cheaper to just keep
them in use and send them around than it is to just store it and hope like
restored.
Eventually like after it's unused for 25 30 years because of all the old horse
hair or whatever is that used to make each thing.
But there's really cool art by Pied de Vinci or who knows what's hidden in some
of these places.
But people that work there know and get to see some of it.
You know what's interesting to me?
People that buy dinosaur skeletons,
apparently there's a giant market for them in China.
They'll spend like a million dollars and buy a dinosaur skeleton that you walk
in this motherfucker's house.
Fuck your artwork,
bitch.
Pretty bad ass.
Damn t rex in my little that you imagine.
Yeah.
He walked into some,
some guys palace,
some Emerald Palace and you open these two fucking teak wood doors and you see a
dinosaur in the middle of his front entrance.
That's what they're going for.
So they're buying these nothing.
Nicolas Cage returned stolen Mongolian dinosaur skull.
He bought at gallery
tyranosaurs.
What does that mean?
Animal tyranosaurs bat?
Have you heard of that now?
T a r will,
it will be repatriated.
Ah,
I like that word.
After it was bought by the actor from Beverly Hills Gallery in 2007 a t rex go,
wow.
What?
He bought it for $276,000 that's pretty good deal.
Well,
I was 2007 I think he said.
Yeah,
she wasn't worth as much back then,
man.
Now nothing stops you in your tracks.
And Like Museum of natural history is a good fucking dinosaur skeleton.
Especially the ones that eat things like eat meat.
I don't want that big ass stupid plan.
Eaton Brontosaurus kid.
That bitch.
I'm like,
yes.
That's a weird elephant.
He's a fucking Vegan.
Who wants to hang out with a Vegan at?
I'm out of here.
I'm not scared.
I want to see teeth.
Let me see teeth and claws.
What's Shit design?
Huh?
Giant head.
A little tiny baby arms.
Yeah,
we'll shit design.
Like what is he doing with those arms?
What the fuck is the purpose of those arms?
And this is the only animal that I can think of that developed that way.
And was that a,
was he a plant eater?
No.
T rex.
Yeah.
[inaudible].
They,
they don't know if t rex was a predator or if t rex was a scavenger.
They think by the shape.
There's some talk that by the shape of his bones than what he might've been
doing was using those bones to crush giant dinosaur bones.
And that like he might be surviving on,
on dead things.
Yeah.
And that they also had some speculation that they might've had their,
they don't want to know what they really looked like because they don't know the
skin color.
They had some speculation that they might've had faces like vultures,
like red fucked up really brightly colored faces just to let you know they're
disgusting and they're hitting,
you know,
cause like when you see vultures,
it's not a coincidence that there the grossest fucking looking animal on the
planet.
All they eat is dead shit in their big vultures are fucking big.
That's a big animal flopping around with these giant wings.
But we're not nearly as impressed by them as we are with an eagle.
And you see like the vultures never going to be the fucking national bird get
out of here with that bullshit.
We killed ourselves bro when I went out here for sale scavenger as fucked up,
red faced stupid bird Smithsonian.
I think it opened some of the 8th of June.
Just start.
They have this brand new deep time.
Oh that's the Irish elk natural history.
A dinosaur exhibit.
And this is some of the highlights of what they have there.
They have this like t rex.
Wow.
Triceratops.
Yeah.
Jeez.
Irish elk,
saber tooth cat.
Bunch of cool stuff.
Like you're just talking about it.
So I'm sure they might have some of these answers to the questions.
And this is a where at which DC Smithsonian natural.
Yes.
When's this come out?
It's opening now.
It's like they just built it and it just doing all the press seems pretty cool.
Yeah,
I mean who owns the dinosaur skeletons?
Who owns that?
At the Smithsonian I think is,
it's free because it's US taxes.
So some of this stuff,
I guess we technically own,
I guess I don't,
I don't see DC or New York.
One of them doesn't.
For any of the museums.
I think it might be DC.
Smithsonian stuff was all free or when it's open,
it should be free.
My friend John Dudley knows a dude who owns a ranch in Montana and they found a
t rex on his property.
No Shit.
Wow.
Found a bone out there moving around stuff on his property.
Look,
what the fuck is this?
So it's cleaning it up.
Find something,
brings in some paleontologists.
They start digging and they're like,
Whoa,
Daddy.
Yeah,
we've got a t rex here.
Alright.
Yeah,
he,
yeah,
that's it.
That's a fucking job.
People get obsessed with that and they go,
I'm going to,
I'm going to be an archeologist when I get older,
and then you're standing in a fucking desert with a toothbrush for eight hours a
day trying to find a bone fudge.
That Dude Sam,
the guy's name from a Sam O'neil,
Sam Neill,
Sam Neil from Jurassic Park.
Yeah.
Nobody wants to be him.
Everybody wants to be.
Jeff Goldbloom.
God shows up with a sexy jacket and says,
um,
life finds a way.
Oh,
it appears,
appears of lifelines away.
World's biggest t rex discovered Jesus Christ.
What does this estimated 19,500 pounds?
[inaudible] Holy Shit.
Holy Shit.
And what can those arms even do?
Look at those dams are weird,
man.
They're so weird.
And look how big the feet and legs are and the giant ass head.
That's the thing that thinking like that this wasn't something that chase things
down.
It just sort of bent over and just jacked whatever was on the ground.
Yeah,
but I don't know if that's like a,
I think there was some speculation we,
we should Google this because there was something about the physics of its body
that it wouldn't be able to run fast because it's so weirdly shaped.
They like trying to figure out why is its head so big.
It has a little tiny ass arms and these big ass legs,
this big fucking tail.
It can that thing run like what,
what?
And then there's also some speculation that the atmosphere was way different
back then
and the atmosphere is what's more oxygen rich.
Maybe things just were different,
you know like the physic could run longer and faster.
Maybe even the physics of earth was a little different in terms of like a,
the way we interacted with the gravity.
We interacted with the atmosphere rather.
Yeah.
The atmosphere like held him up somehow or another.
Like it was thicker.
But I read things that I'm high and I don't remember what the fuck.
I think this is just saying that it could,
it should have been slower maybe than like they're shown in the drastic park.
It wouldn't have been running that for here it says running would have broken
and adult time ran a source,
wrecks his legs.
See that don't but go,
okay Google this cause.
So now we know that there's people that think that he couldn't run because of
the shape.
Google,
the atmosphere was different during the Jurassic period
because there was some,
I mean it might've been horse shit.
It was just an article that was written about how like we have to take into
account the whole world was like different before that giant asteroid came and
fucked up everything and slammed into Cheech needs Eatsa,
you know that uh,
the oxygen levels might have been about 20 to 30% higher during that time
period.
So like it might've been harder to breathe,
I guess.
I'm not sure.
Hard to debrief a sudden drop in oxygen from roughly 30% of the atmosphere of
the atmosphere to about 10% may have contributed to mass extinctions.
Oh.
So from the impact,
the dinosaurs.
So that was one of the things they thought killed.
There's a bunch of different ideas that they have of how quickly the dinosaurs
died off.
But one of the more interesting ones that I saw recently was that they all died
almost instantly.
It says it would've made it,
he more humid with higher levels of carbon dioxide and more likely more cloud
cover.
Hmm.
It just,
it's gasping for breath harder.
I just keep seeing that stuff.
It's just harder
breathe during that.
Yeah.
That doesn't have anything to do with the way they moved though.
There was something about,
I remember reading something about the way a t rex moved,
but it's a fucking mystery cause it's not like you look at a crocodile,
you're like,
oh,
I get it.
Uses those four legs to get you with this big fat face.
You know?
It makes sense.
Then you look at a t rex like,
why are you up in the air like that?
Why is your head so big?
What's with the little legs?
The ones in the front,
one of those things.
What's the,
the arms.
What's up with this weird body?
You have the weight of that head.
Is He large,
giant head?
Yeah.
It's crazy.
He needs to go to Indianapolis.
Get that thing fucking shake down is an insult.
Maybe that's why some mad
kept.
Fuck.
How did they follow the fuck?
How do they fuck Jesus Christ with that tail?
How do you get at the Pussy with that tail?
That's a crazy ass tail.
You'd have to come at it from the side.
You'd have to tackle her.
You don't have to blind cider.
Tackle her.
Get a leg up in the air,
get in like that.
You'd have to get one of them.
But then what the fuck?
You have no arms now she can get away and job t rex tiny arms may have been
vicious weapons.
Save it.
Nerd.
What?
Like unlike his fucking giant face filled with huge swords,
he's got a huge head filled with swords.
Tradeoff,
remnants of little wings of flightless bird
bird it.
That's what I thought.
I was looking at my thought.
Maybe at one point I had heard that there's some loss.
One scientist thought those were like remnants of,
yeah,
some
wings.
Oh,
that makes sense.
And then we're actually maybe arms but their wings.
Well that totally makes sense when you think about like ostriches and shit like
that,
that they used to have wings and they turned to those things.
Let me see it again.
Let me see his fucking little shitty arms.
That makes me way more sense.
That makes way more sense.
The remnants of four wings cause like that.
If you think about what an ostrich looks like,
you could kind of morph an ostrich into a t rex,
right?
Yeah.
I mean they don't have a tail,
but they do have those fucked up legs,
giant ass legs,
and a weird body and a fucking head.
And when they look at you,
they look at you like they look right through you.
Like you don't mean Shit.
Like if you got run over by a truck in front of an ostrich,
they wouldn't even flinch.
They don't give a fuck about you now.
And just like a dinosaur,
they just have this bird face.
Yeah.
They have zero compassion for you.
Ask.
Just have no empathy.
That's why they have small arms.
They never hug anybody.
No assholes.
All of those.
All those fucking creatures that fly around or used to,
they can all talk it.
Allbirds Allbirds are gross.
I love when people keep them as pets.
See if you can find,
um,
o p a bird is better.
Loves me.
Yeah.
Keep your window open.
See what happens.
A T rex used to look like vulture.
This is a weird one.
They don't even know what they were covering.
Feathers.
They think it might have been covered in feathers.
That's a more recent speculation.
They think that all dinosaurs were covered in feathers.
Wow.
Yeah.
Or most of them,
you know,
that's why you know,
you see chickens.
Chicken litter literally is at dinosaur.
Just one that lived one that made it.
Oh,
that's one.
That's creepy looking.
Um,
now there was one where it had a red face.
There was some,
uh,
yeah,
that's it right there.
That exactly.
Yeah.
So yeah,
that's how they had it done with like feathers and shit.
Feathers in a big old red face.
I don't know why we're attached to like one idea what that fucking thing look
like.
All we have is bones.
They have no idea what the skin was like easily could have been covered in
feathers.
Is it amazing that every kid,
I don't know if it's girls too,
but every boy gets fascinated with dinosaurs at a certain age.
Isn't that weird?
Oh yeah.
It's like archetypal.
There's something deep in your brain that wants to know and connect with
dinosaurs when you're like four or five years old because it's such a fucking
wild hail Mary by nature and they they ruled for so long and they were snuffed
out by or Brock.
Like if that rock didn't hit earth,
we would be under the reign of these vicious fucking reptiles roaming the
planet,
eating everything.
We would have never evolved to where we are.
We would have been hiding in little holes in the ground.
We'd be a little mammals.
This is good as you're ever going to get.
You're never going to develop a fucking city.
Good luck pitches raptors everywhere.
There's just running around Jack.
You don't think homo sapiens would have never,
never made it.
Never got to that part.
We were moles for hundreds of millions of years.
We were these weird fucking creatures and then from 65 million years ago,
that mole evolved into a human being.
According to these fucking scientists,
all their fancy,
they have $65,000 a year that you have to pay for education.
This book I was just listening to about music and the brain talked about the
first instrument found is this a,
I think it was like a rib flute of like an elephant or a something that's like
50,000 years old,
but because it's a flute they go,
that's probably most likely not the first instrument being used because it was
probably drums to get into a flute.
That's making sounds.
It's a big evolution.
Like how,
how far back do you think they were just using drums before they had language,
you know,
let's have the Haka and New Zealand,
that whole thing,
which is just a lot of sounds in the ground screaming.
But that was a way to communicate.
Yeah.
Like,
um,
what is the accepted timeline for the invention of language?
I don't know what it is,
but let's take a guess.
Um,
I want to say language was invented a hundred thousand years ago.
What do you think?
I don't even think it's that.
Well,
it have been,
I'm going to say it's 40.
I'm going to say language was invented 40,000 years ago.
Homosapian right?
Is that,
yes.
But homosapien didn't always have language.
Right.
Homosapien I think is 250,000 plus years old.
There's like the argument from like two 50 tickets,
shaky to like 300 5,400 whatever the whatever it could be.
But they think somewhere around there.
And the other thing is like they intersected with,
was it neanderthal man that came beforehand and originally they just thought
that one ended and the next one started.
But then in fact they actually existed together for a long time and they fought.
Yup.
And they fucked.
And neanderthal was around way longer.
The NFL survive for half a million years.
So neanderthal was alive way longer than humans have been alive.
Then modern homo sapiens.
What's up?
Everything I keep finding just says like it starts with ancient Egypt.
Like that can't be right.
Maybe written.
That's probably like written language.
Spoken language at the origin,
date of spoken language.
Well on the Andy Warhol was bigger and stronger,
but homosapien they organized.
Yeah.
Well they work with,
they work as a group.
What really happened because neanderthals actually have bigger brains.
Oh really?
Yeah.
But they're also built way better,
way,
way different.
So it might've been the,
they're bigger brains was to control.
They're much stronger body cause they were like five,
seven,
250 pounds.
20 pounds.
Yeah.
They were built different than us.
They were thick ass bones man.
Like a five,
seven,
200 pound man today.
Like man that guy has got to be lifting some weights.
It's basically my height.
I'm five,
eight I weight 200 pounds.
So I'm built like in the inner tall,
like legitimately,
yes,
they were all built like that in thicker.
Right.
But with Wade,
denser bones,
bigger heads,
bigger arms,
bigger bones,
the bones,
the forearm,
the arms,
the legs,
everything was thicker.
They were just more sturdy than us.
They're like naturally like they didn't have to lift weights.
They would rip your fucking arms off.
They were just built like almost like a half a chimp like on the way from being,
you know,
Australia or you know,
Homo Erectus or Australia Pythius or any of those early man cut type species.
They were in that,
you know,
there's,
there was a,
they think there was dozens of them.
They think that there's the ones that are Russia that they found out about,
I think they're called Denisovans.
There's those a little hobbit,
people that were in,
um,
Australia Flores for us.
They think there might be ones in those places too.
Even in Vietnam,
they have a one they call the orange pen deck.
I think it's how you say it.
And they,
that's a like a little monkey man,
like a little hairy man that lives in the forest out there.
And before this,
a hobbit discovery,
which was holding like a decade ago,
the people that live in the island of Flores and they found out that there was
absolutely three foot tall,
a little hairy people that had stone tools and you know,
and they organized,
they lived in these places and they use fire.
Like that's a,
that's a really bad damn thing.
Yeah.
And they just found that out within the last decade or so.
So I mean,
how many of them were out there?
How many other ones are out there that we just don't have fossils of.
And when you talk to God like Graham Hancock,
who has that amazing book right there called America before.
Fuck,
that's a good book.
It can't find these deep in that
it's about 10,000 years ago.
Seems to be the most agreed upon.
10,000 potential for it for spoken language.
I only have evidence that goes back that far.
There's people that say it's probably should go back as far back as 60,000
years.
But I know,
I don't believe there have any evidence of that to support that.
How would you,
and that's the problem when they developed,
uh,
the larynx,
the voice box,
I think they,
they trace it to that.
Yeah.
That's the problem with history,
right?
Like who knows what the Fuck Lincoln said.
All we know is what Lincoln wrote.
Okay.
When you have Lincoln holding hands with his boyfriend going for walk through
the garden bits,
you just making shit up.
You make that a thing.
Now look,
there are,
there is speculation that Abraham Lincoln was a gay man.
Huh?
And then he slept with a man for a long periods of time,
um,
in the same bed.
But apparently people did that very often back then for warmth because uh,
you know,
you lived in a place that was made out of wood that you chopped down your
fucking self and should've been for four years.
So listen,
when I just cold for four years in a row,
I'd be tough to share a bed with Lincoln.
He was fucking huge.
Yeah.
He's all strong too.
So wrestler Waze.
Yeah.
Huh.
He was an excellent wrestler.
Supposedly shared a bed with his captain,
captain of his body guards whenever his wife was away,
hip hop arrays.
So maybe it was cold.
Hey.
Um,
it might be both me now we have to,
you know,
think about it in context.
Right?
I think if you go back to the Greeks and the Romans,
gay sex was way more common.
I mean it was like almost like everybody was half guy,
right?
It's kind of,
and pedophilia was just a normal thing.
Young boys,
like if you read Socrates,
he read the history of of him or have a lot of scholars in like really respected
thinkers.
They had young boys
that they would bang.
So what was what today is a horrific crime against humanity was completely
normal back then.
Yeah.
So when did that stop?
When a dude's to stop banging and dudes and did they just kind of do it and not
talk about it or was it,
it seems like a
Christianity first brought about the shame,
the sexual shame that we have today.
So I would probably trace it back to like 2000 years ago.
If you how,
here's the question,
how much of being gay is stopped by society's expectations?
Like what is the percentage of people who are actually gay who just can't act on
it because it just,
it whether their mom or their religion or their church they go to,
or the,
you know,
the God married and they had kids,
but they really want to be gay.
How much of that exists today?
Look what percentage out of all,
all the gay activity,
if you could put it on a pie chart,
how many more gay people would there be if they didn't?
If there was just no one cares to?
Yeah.
There's no expectations from religion.
No expectations from your community?
Ibm.
What'd you mean?
Fuck yeah.
Do you think you'd be a top or a bottom top?
That's what everybody thinks
I'd be,
I'd be a screaming bottom.
A lot of crying.
I'd be a running bottom.
It would be just like when you were waterboarded,
you'd be fucking spasming uncontrollably
and it turns out that that's what a lot of the guys are into.
Unfortunately.
Just sets the biggest [inaudible] in the community.
Waterboarding but fucked.
Getting Butt fucked by waterboarding.
It's the new black,
it's the new thing.
Yeah,
it's the rage.
It's all the rage nipple clamps and,
hmm.
Did you ever watch orange is the new black couple times?
Is there any good?
It's not bad.
I just,
I didn't,
I felt like the character Jews
were a little too over,
over drawn.
I didn't buy them as real people too much.
They seem like it felt like a writer coming up with a character as opposed to
like really trying to portray human behavior.
But then again,
I've never been in a women's prison.
My mom worked in a women's prison for years.
Dude.
Really?
Yeah,
she talked about,
they were all victims.
We were talking about earlier about,
um,
you know,
women who were abused,
abused,
and every fucking,
one of them was abused sexually,
physically.
Almost all of them are in jail because of a guy they were carrying drugs for a
guy.
They stay fucking killed the guy because he kept attacking her.
It was pretty rare,
you know,
and a lot of it was obviously drug use,
but
that stems from usually childhood abuse.
Yeah.
But for a lot of them,
my mom said it was the best environment they'd ever lived in because there was a
solidarity among a lot of the women.
There was a lot of support.
There was education,
there were support groups and uh,
and they developed relationships with women without men around.
And so they were able to foster and nurture real female empowered relationships.
That's so sad and cool at the same time.
Yeah,
it's sad,
but it's like,
well,
it's nice that something is working out for them.
Like women in jail seemed to have a way better time of it than men in jail just
seems like a better deal I think.
So.
You probably not getting beat up as much.
Isn't there a new reality show about women in jail with her following these
women?
Not just women.
It's mostly women that follow.
I saw that sa called jailbirds on Netflix.
I watched like the first steps.
Right?
Is that good?
Is that bad?
Yeah.
It follows them in like the Sacramento jail holding or it seems like there's so
many fucking shows about people in jail that it must be like prisoners must get
agents now get off.
I got an offer from MSNBC for lockup.
Greg,
they like you,
but they'd like you to just get some face tattoos.
Do you think you'd be good?
You know they'll put you on a Annie.
Okay.
Annie,
bad guys show.
Think of any size in jail.
Greg Fitzsimmons on them.
We're giving you a two year option,
but I'm only in here for one.
You Follow Golf,
right?
Yeah.
I wanted to talk to you about this because it's so ridiculous.
I saw this guy got suspended from his serious golf show because,
uh,
he was talking about the Lpga and he goes,
who,
who's gonna win the LPGA?
He goes,
let me go out on a limb and say it's going to be a Korean.
Cause apparently Koreans when a lot of them,
70% of the LPGA is Korean.
It's crazy.
Somebody said,
uh,
he goes,
could pick a name.
He goes,
uh,
is it Lee?
He goes,
how many leads do we have that entered in?
It's like six Lee's six leads.
Was there six Lee's,
they said he was racist and sexist and they suspended him for those comments.
Like,
first of all,
it's not bad to win.
Okay.
When he's saying who do you think's gonna win?
Probably a Korean.
Well that's good.
That means the Koreans kick ass at golf.
That's a fucking racist.
Is Not racist to say that.
It's also not racist to say,
ah,
maybe their name is Lee.
Cause there's a lot of Lee's that's not racist.
That's accurate.
It turns out there was six Lee's yeah,
like,
come on folks.
We're not saying anything bad.
You're talking about something that everybody loves,
which is golf.
Right.
You all love it.
That's why you're listening to golf radio and talking about an impoverished
country that is found a way like black people found boxing or Irish guys,
uh,
found the fucking police force.
Like you find something to rise up out of.
Well,
Korean harbor card,
I mean,
a guarantee.
That's
part of it.
Yeah,
it's part,
it's part of the culture.
I had a very good friend of mine that I've talked about many times in this
podcast who was us national champ while he was in medical school,
national taekwondo champion.
And I realized how hard some people,
oh yeah.
Junk.
Sick Chang.
That was his name.
Yeah.
Great Guy.
One of my favorite people I've ever met.
I loved him to death
women.
But in men's golf and men's golf is very international now.
It's never had more players from around the world,
but not a lot of Koreans.
It's like a Japanese guy who's way up top and there's another Korean guys.
Good.
But nothing like Lpga.
That's interesting.
I don't know anything about,
I didn't know anything about Koreans in golf before I saw that.
But we have to make a differentiation between something that is about a race and
something that's racist.
This is not negative.
You're literally talking about a positive thing.
They're winners.
You want to win.
Don't you want to,
when you're trying to win,
right.
Well,
they win a lot.
They're awesome at it.
And it's not,
they're not cheating.
They're just kicking ass.
They're better at golf.
Yeah,
and some of them are named Lee.
There's nothing racist here.
This is not right.
They're upset because the ratings for the LPGA or way down because they want to
see Americans playing.
So there's like a,
so it's an issue.
Yeah,
it's a big issue because the ratings,
you think his attitude is racist because he's like mocking it because Koreans
winning it so he doesn't care.
I don't know that.
I don't know that that's his,
that's tension.
No,
I don't think it's as intention.
I think there's a sensitivity about it because it's become an issue.
I'd get that.
I get that.
That makes sense.
But it just doesn't make sense if you're just going off of what he said right
off what he said.
What I'm getting is you're being super fucking sensitive with how you,
how you treat people that are talking about winners.
Yeah.
Like that's the case with uh,
Filipinos and pool.
Filipinos are some of the greatest pool players of all time.
Some of my all time favorite pool players are from the Philippines.
Um,
Francisco Bustamante Efrin Rayez,
Rodolfo,
Lou [inaudible],
Alex,
Peggy,
Elian,
some of the greatest of all time.
Uh,
Dennis or Coolo,
all those guys were Filipino.
Those are the top of the food chain man.
When you saw those guys playing a tournament,
like fuck,
like you knew they were winning.
Yeah,
I mean F and raise one.
Everything Bustamante one,
everything's guys are murderers.
And if you said like,
who's going to win this tournament?
Probably a Filipino.
Everybody would start laughing like,
yeah,
probably they wouldn't be a negative.
It'd be a positive there.
The,
some of the best in the world.
That pool.
That's odd.
Racist.
That's accurate.
Yeah.
Now what is it with it,
with MMA,
what are,
what are the big nationalities is,
that's a good question.
Russians,
the
Russians are murdering it right now.
There's a lot of bad ass rushes.
Wherever life is hard.
You're going to find fighters and you're find people that survive where life is
hard and thrive.
And then that's how you get like a cubby number gummit off.
He get a hard mother fucker who knows how to fight and then it scares shit.
Same thing with Conor McGregor.
You get a hard neighborhood,
hard life,
you know,
growing up in Dublin,
dangerous fighting since he was young,
you know,
that's how you get these beasts and then you get American MMA guys come from
wrestling or the military.
Right.
Yet some of them,
some of them from the military,
you know,
it's rare.
You know,
we had special forces guy like Tim Kennedy,
of course,
he's probably one of the most famous Brian Stan.
I'm also a military veteran.
And you look at these guys that are,
you know,
the,
the guys that are capable of being seals or rangers are green berets.
They're just elite humans.
They're just,
they're people that know how to do things and push themselves in a way that
other people don't.
Sometimes that translates over the fighting and sometimes it doesn't,
you know,
sometimes they just don't have the physical capability of it.
Like they might have the mindset to survive war and the ability to get through
buds and to get through grueling physical training.
But he ain't beat John Jones.
You know,
like there's,
there's levels to this thing and this genetic levels,
you know,
Jon Jones says like some of the best genetics ever and then uses them as good as
anybody that's ever existed best at controlling distance of all time.
He's got two brothers that are NFL players,
so this is like super genetics in the house.
Both his brothers are NFL stars.
That's amaze and he's the baddest light heavyweight of all time.
Any smart.
So it's not just physical,
it's also intellectual.
He's also sets traps for people.
He measured them,
he sees what they're doing and he fails him,
weaken any pressures and puts heavy pressure on people he knows when to ebb and
flow.
He's just a genius at fighting.
The lightweights have longer careers?
No,
no.
I would say the opposite.
I would say the bigger guys actually have,
uh,
they,
they can compete at a higher level deep into their 30s and even forties.
Like Randy coture I think,
I think he really won the heavyweight title when he was 42 check cause I would
think there'd be more knockouts with heavyweights.
There's a lot of knockouts with heavy weights,
but they,
their bodies maintain what got them to the dance later in life.
Like George Foreman,
George Foreman won the heavyweight title,
I think he was 46 when he knocked out Michael Moore.
So the oldest ever heavyweight champion and that's just unheard of at
welterweight.
You're not going to see 46 year old welterweights winning the world title
against Earl Spence Jr someone like that.
You just not going to see that 43,
he was 43.
Brandy was,
yeah.
And find out how old George Foreman was when he knocked out Michael Moore.
So that's crazy.
That's crazy.
Old 43 you don't see that at 125 pounds.
You just don't,
you just don't know.
125 pounds.
No one wins the title at 43 years.
It's just the mass almost helps you survive something like that.
I also think they lose less as they get older.
He was 45 45 so yeah,
George Foreman was the oldest ever heavyweight at 45 crazy.
Wow.
That is so unusual as like a middleweight.
The only one who maintained a world championship caliber,
uh,
skillset deep into his forties was Bernard Hopkins and Archie Moore when Archie
Moore was younger.
I'm going to put some,
you know,
we're talking about the rocky Marciano days.
That was,
he fought deep into his forties as well,
but he was just like a real crafty veteran.
He actually also trained George Foreman,
which is very interesting.
So like that crafty veteran trained George Foreman to be a crafty veteran and
maintain his power.
He had a real unusual,
I remember to remember,
but George Foreman used to almost like put his hands up like he didn't know how
to fight.
Like,
Hey,
don't hit me.
Don't hit me.
It almost like that.
But that was his defense.
He would move forward like this.
Cause he was so big,
he was such an enormous man with these enormous arms.
So when you would stack them on top of each other and walk towards you like
that,
it was this weird offerance and he learned that from Archie Moore who was part
of the part of his defense and holding his hands up in a weird way.
He learned from Archie Moore,
right.
Well,
you know,
uh,
the oldest,
a hockey player in the NHL is also the biggest six foot eight guy is a Dana
Chara.
All the Bruins fan
43.
What's that name?
What is his name?
Zidane.
Achara what?
Slovakian he,
that dude was from the Lord of the rings.
Look,
let's listen to that thing that gave birth to him in a meadow.
They rode a horse out there.
It was destiny.
They predict how long he been.
I was young.
Yeah.
Just that name.
He came out of eight is a fucking viking.
He's an animal.
He fights.
I saw,
Oh yeah,
I saw this one fight where he hit a guy and the guy kind of took a dive and he,
he leaned down and picked him up with one hand and started punching him with the
other,
lifted him off the ice with one hand.
Yeah.
I saw one thing that guy did that's really fucked up a guy,
a hip toss to dude.
He judo through him.
Like he swept him.
Like he grabbed a hold of them,
swept his leg up,
kicked his leg out like Uchi Mata and slammed his fucking head onto the ground.
Geez.
It was rough.
Yeah.
I was like,
man,
that ain't the same as fighting like you,
you,
you know you're on ice.
Yeah.
He maybe,
no one's told me couldn't do it.
Right.
But he used some really fucking sneaky shit.
Yeah.
You know?
The F the F,
the fighting and the NHS.
It's funny,
there's a,
there's really great clips of guys talking to each other before fights and it's
amazingly calm.
They literally go like,
uh hey,
you want to go and the guy,
I'll be like,
y'all go and then they fight and then they throw and then as soon as the other
guy,
cause yeah,
they just throw their gloves down and they start fighting.
It's all,
it's all part of the game.
It's all fucking orchestrated.
And there's players that fight and there's players that don't and if you're on
a,
if you're on the ice with another goon,
then it's,
it's expected that you guys are going to fight at some point.
Yeah.
What a crazy way to make
a living bare knuckle fighting up slippery floor.
Yeah.
But you know,
they don't,
they don't get hit that much because they get to Jersey up.
They do.
They get hit enough though.
Yeah.
I've been watching dudes who have skills.
Now you're seeing way more guys who have boxing skills,
right.
Doing this like guys who like laying like short uppercuts and left hooks where
you like,
Oh my God,
I've got to turn that punch over.
That guy knows how to punch.
Yeah.
Not as many over hands where you're all you're doing with the overhead and the
guy in the helmet with your fist.
Yeah,
the flailing.
Sometimes you don't see that.
Sometimes you've seen guys would throw fucking straight punches and like,
all right,
I love you.
Don't know how to fight,
and then this guy knows how to do that while he's out.
Yeah.
This one,
look at this.
Boom,
boom.
Becka knockout bowls at home.
Well that's a good Kao while he's hold and then he gives them one way is going
down and then he goes down.
He's out cold.
Yeah.
Boom.
Fang guys out.
Oh yeah.
He believes his right from the shoulder.
That guy can punch.
He's and he's,
you're punching in the face while he's punching you in the face too.
It's chaos.
It's a terrible way to find people.
Not only a great fighter,
one of the best players in the league,
and also a great fighter.
Wow.
That's a crazy sport.
Man.
Doesn't get enough love.
Yeah.
Name names.
Get the average person name a famous hockey players currently playing.
I know this,
the same guy.
This crazy thing happened this year.
This is an insane video to watch.
I can't show it.
Every people at home might have seen this,
but the puck literally flies and hits him right in the face and he barely moves
as it might've should show it again in slow motion right here
to see if his teeth got knocked out.
Oh Man.
You've got parked right in the mug.
Yeah Bro.
That is hard.
Wow.
That guy can take it.
Fuck it now.
It's insane.
The fucking Bruins.
And I actually dropped game one last night against the blues,
but the Bruins are set to win the Stanley Cup,
which means Boston.
We'll win the fucking super bowl,
the world series and the Stanley Cup
one year.
I remember when we lived there,
they couldn't win shit.
It was like they had such an inferiority complex.
Yeah.
And then we get close,
like the Celtics were good.
They had Larry Bird and Danny Ainge and have it forever.
Cause like when was the last time the Yankees won the world series?
How long ago was that cheese?
um,
eight.
So it's been 11 years.
I know I could be way off on that,
but they still have it.
There's still the Yankees,
you know what I mean?
But for the Red Sox,
they never pulled it off.
And then that bill Buckner thing,
Bill Buckner just died.
Oh,
so sad.
Yeah.
And that's the thing about being in Bali,
because I grew up a mets fan.
We had season tickets to the met since I was a little kid.
And so when they get into the world series and I was going to school in Boston,
surrounded by mass halls watching these fucking games and they're just,
I'm sorry if you're from Boston,
take it the fuck easy about your sports.
They're so loud.
Like,
like,
like last night with the,
with the a Bruins game.
They uh,
they boo the entire,
they introduced the,
the blues,
they boo every fucking,
it's just,
it's barbaric.
The animals.
So then fucking Buckner,
who is this storied amazing player who's a journeyman,
he's been out there for ever.
They put them at first base.
He used to be an outfielder,
but he slowed down.
I think he had bad legs or some say put them at first base.
He gets a fucking ball hit to him it,
it took a bad hop,
watch the video.
It took a bad hop and he missed it and they fucking,
there were death threats.
They dropped him that year.
He went down to Pawtucket in Rhode Island's plan.
The miners,
they showed up there and fucking terrorized him.
He had to move out to like Arizona to hide.
Jeez.
Cause these fucking Boston fans.
I remember people walking the streets.
What year was that?
80 46 86 I remember people walking the streets,
they'd just be walking around the neighborhood with their hands in their hair
like fuck you after they lost.
Fuck yeah.
Just walk in the street.
Yeah.
We're so mad.
It was all anybody wanted to talk about.
All right,
because they hadn't won a world series since 2017 or something.
It was crazy.
I was early 2019 17 yeah,
1917 I was already over baseball at that point.
I wasn't interested in baseball anymore.
So for me it was really fascinating to watch.
Yeah.
Watch these people cause I had grown from caring about baseball to being
obsessed with martial arts and that was in the tree,
like got obsessed with martial arts and like 81.
So by the time 86 rolled around I was like,
what the fuck are you people paying attention to?
Some guy dropped a ball,
you're going to be okay.
Yeah.
What is this?
Not only that,
but that same year,
I believe it was that same year,
the um,
the mets that same year that the Patriots lost to the bears in the Superbowl and
they guy was one of the biggest blowouts in Superbowl history.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
They were riding off of that too.
It was rough times.
Half Times for Boston.
Yeah.
I,
I don't want to live there cause I can't deal with the cold.
I'm too too much of a pussy these days.
Yeah.
But I love those fucking animals.
Oh,
Boston the best.
I fucking love Boston different man.
Yup.
The characters,
the different growing up there.
I think for both of us,
like to start and to start our comedy careers there,
I think it was insanely valuable.
Yeah.
Cause they're not taking any bullshit.
They're,
they're not.
They're not taking any half ass act that's slow and meandering and self
absorbed.
Not happening now.
And it's still like that still.
Like I was just there and it's like they don't,
here's what,
here's what it is.
When you walk on stage in Boston,
the audience doesn't automatically by default give you credit for being in
charge.
You have to earn it every time we are first year.
First Joke in Boston is fucking clots.
You got to get up there and get a laugh fast.
It's fucking cold there in the winter.
It makes harder people.
Yeah,
that's right.
It makes people that know how to get past that fucking hump.
Yeah.
That's all three month hump where it's socks.
You remember that?
Yeah.
It's brutal.
Umber.
It's fucking windy
down to stitches.
I'll fucking calm APP.
It's fucking freezing and getting through the door.
Just trembling while you wait for the train outdoors.
How about a fucking underground stuff.
No.
Outside,
outside.
Outside.
Nobody.
Right.
Fuck you.
Yeah.
That be so much together.
But he's freezing every time the door opens.
If it was fucking freezing,
fuck,
fuck.
Yeah.
Get in your car in the morning to start it like,
fuck,
fuck.
Yeah.
All right,
so cold.
And then they also have the,
it's a,
it's an immigrant city too,
you know,
they edit all the Italians and the Irish.
They all came in and they fucking fought it out over real estate where they were
going to live,
who's going to get the union jobs and it created a very tough [inaudible].
It's like Philly or the Bronx.
There's just cities where they had that,
that fighting at the turn of the century.
Yeah.
And I think it's the,
it was the magical ingredient for stand up.
That's part of the magical ingredient.
The magical ingredient wasn't just that.
There was guys like Barry Crimmins and Lenny Clarke and Steve Sweeney and dawn
Gavin and Mike Donovan and all these brilliant comedians that we saw that we
were so lucky to see.
It was also that they,
they were being,
their audiences were savages.
Yeah.
So they're like,
great,
how about another joke,
you know?
Great.
How about another one?
Like they'll like kick coming in,
come with the jokes,
jokes.
Like they want joke,
joke,
joke.
Like those guys,
like when you would watch like Lenny Clarke murderer room,
you,
there was no,
no one's getting a break.
There's no breathing room.
You just getting pounded.
Yeah.
He's just smashing you.
Like those guys developed in that style where people just were constantly
wanting to be amused.
Like,
let's go,
let's go with the fucking Mandarin.
Yeah.
They,
well,
they want it.
They want it with attitude.
They were anti authoritarian attitude.
It was always like,
I remember Kenny Rogers since joke of like,
uh,
I remember,
I'm not saying I was drinking a lot,
but I,
uh,
I drove into a lake,
got pulled over by the coast guard.
They said I had been drinking.
I go,
I'm going to lake.
It was always just fuck you too with other,
you know.
Yeah.
Everything was like,
so I'm doing a bump.
Yeah.
Everything was like do it lines and drinking and chaos.
Jon Tobin who runs the uh,
laugh Boston,
he's telling me this story.
He's a fucking,
if you ever want to hear Gavin stories for an hour straight,
go to lunch with Jon Tobin and bring a fucking handkerchief cause he's got Don
Gavin's stories.
He's talking about how Gavin who likes to drink white Russians does a late show
and goes up there and repeats a joke and he walks off stage and one of the
Comedians goes,
uh,
Don,
you said the same joke twice up there and he goes records six,
six times.
Oh my God.
How drunk are you?
Like on death's door?
You're like rubbing your face on door of death
will come low,
let me.
But it's also the not giving a shit that he did it six times and go fuck,
give a fuck.
Give a fuck.
He's still didn't give a fuck last time I saw him still don Gavin.
How's a slow down drinking?
One hand,
big smile on his face.
He's always been my favorite.
He's one of the greatest of all time in my opinion.
From what I've seen.
I mean,
he was so sharp in the 80s and the early nineties when we were around,
he was so sharp.
He,
his,
his punchlines would come one after the other and you didn't see him comment and
they would just catch you off guard.
Little offbeat punchlines.
Yeah.
We'll throw away like throwaway line.
That was like some of the funny shit you ever heard that,
that whole bit that he used to do about going to a salad bar.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
He was a murderer.
He goes up front,
they got chickpeas in the back.
He got the lobster given you the finger,
which is so lucky,
man.
We're so lucky.
We got to experience that because I think it's so different out here now.
Like where we're at now is like,
um,
like if comedy was an education,
w were hanging around with a bunch of tenured professors,
right in La.
Yeah.
Everyone's gotten tenure.
Everyone's like,
uh,
you know,
whether it's just the neck or you know,
Neal Brennan or you are,
this is just a gang of headliners,
like a,
a swamp of headliners.
But when we were doing it,
man,
it was so uncertain.
There was not,
there was not that thing where there was like this established community of like
nationally touring stand up comedians that you were around all the time.
You didn't have it.
Yeah.
Nobody had any TV credits,
nobody bloody any TV credit.
One headliner.
It was all about,
and the beauty of it was,
it was a total meritocracy because there were guys like,
you know Gavin and sweet.
There was,
there were half a dozen guys that could draw and the rest of us were hired
because there was a comedy night.
Somebody's fucking hand drew comedy on a sign and put it in front of a Chinese
restaurant and you showed up and you've got booked because the booker thought
you could kill.
It's all that mattered was that you could do a good job and said,
can you do it?
CanNot their credits you have not one fucking Twitter account you have.
Once you got credit,
so then you could do the road.
That was the difference.
Yeah.
To get out of Boston.
You needed a credit.
Yeah.
When you're doing the road.
They all wanted to know what TV show you've been on.
They all wanted to know that.
Yeah.
Have you done comedy spotlight?
What about half hour comedy hour?
Have you done this?
If you had HBO special.
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
That was the bomb.
Diggity your headline and every club you wanted to,
he goes,
guys got an HBO special.
But back then everyone that we knew had nothing.
I remember Budd Friedman came to town in the early nineties when it was evening
at the Improv was like the original strip shot stand up comedy show that put it
on the map,
put a and e on the map.
It was their first big show.
I remember he to town and there was a showcase at duck soup and uh,
we all,
we all went up and then Budd Friedman,
who fucking great guy,
takes us all out to dinner afterwards and sits us down and he goes,
goes through each of us.
He goes,
you did a great job.
You need a little bit more work.
I liked that that bit.
You did A,
and he gets a day Fitzgerald and he goes,
you got it,
you're doing the show.
And we were just all like fuck
Fitzgerald when people thought they forgot about he was very funny.
Yeah,
he was great.
Very funny.
Tight,
great drinking stories.
Yeah.
He's another guy that found his a stage legs during alcoholics anonymous
meetings.
Right.
There's a few of those guys.
He's like,
yeah.
You know,
they say they say you go to Aa meetings and you end up just getting it
addicted to coffee.
Yeah.
I never walked out of a Dunkin donuts with the Willdabeast on my arm.
My um,
my um,
my,
um,
and the more Boston accent you had in Boston,
the more they loved you.
Yeah.
You know?
All right,
Len,
he was the only one who had legitimate credits.
Cause at that time,
like even in the 80s,
Lenny had already been on Rodney Dangerfield special.
The HPO.
Yeah.
I think when I worked with them,
it was after he had been on Rodney Dangerfield saga.
I had plenty on like three weeks ago,
four weeks ago.
He was a fucking hilarious.
He's still so funny.
Man.
Yeah,
he's all healthy now.
Totally sober exercises.
But uh,
I opened up for him like the second time I ever got paid and I think it was
after he had already been on Hbo,
I think it was like right afterwards.
So he was a terribly partying with Kennison and he was in the middle of like
his,
his run where he started.
Got You've got a television show out here.
He talked about that too,
about how he got ripped off his agents stole all of his money.
No Shit.
You don't know that story.
Oh God.
I'll send you the link.
I don't want to repeat the story cause you want to,
you want to hear him say
wow.
There was a big scandal.
Those,
his thinking was called spotlight agency.
I forget what the spotlight number.
They stole everybody's money.
Yep.
Yeah,
they still Landry buddy's money.
Yeah.
One agent just,
yeah,
they used to put a lot of colleges and stuff.
Um,
but,
uh,
but there's a story about how Jim Mccauley,
who booked the tonight show forever,
he said he'd heard about Boston and he's like,
and they're telling me this is back in like maybe the mid eighties and they're
telling them about how you got to go to Boston.
All the great comics are in Boston now you've got to,
you know,
talking about all the names we just said.
So he sets up a showcase at the,
what was that?
That Chinese restaurant that was like the original
room.
Which one?
Cow loon.
No beef.
Way Back.
Oh,
the Ding Ho.
They set up a showcase of the Ding Ho and all the guys come down and they're in
the green room and they're drinking,
they're doing blow,
they're cracking each other up and they all go up there and they do fucking,
you know,
local references and they're doing jokes about the Boston accent.
And Mccall is just sitting there going,
what the fuck is going on in here?
And then Steven,
right?
Yeah,
goes up.
And he does Steven Wright and,
and they find out a couple of days later,
nobody got it.
Except Steven Wright and Steven,
right at that time,
Lenny told him,
I think it was Lenny,
one of them sat Steven Wright down and goes,
Steve,
you're a sweet guy.
You're terrific kid.
This isn't for you.
Because he used to bomb and Boston because he was,
he was monotone and you know,
he was doing his shtick and it didn't play in Boston.
We did for these guys.
They told him you should stop.
And then he got the tonight show.
They fly him out.
He does a set.
Johnny liked him so much.
They said,
can you stay another week?
Did another spot.
And in that first year he must've done for tonight shows and he became fucking
huge.
You've got a special out of it and they're all sitting at home,
gone like I fucking killed that night.
He didn't kill him.
Yeah.
Whoops.
Tell him to quit.
That's hilarious.
Comedy.
The only been around for 30 years.
Yeah.
You tell him to quit.
Nobody knows how to do it yet.
All right.
You don't imagine I'm,
I'm an expert in this.
You gotta quit like nobody.
Nobody can really tell you that.
You can never figure it out because comedy is not that different than anything
else.
And that if you really put a lot of time and effort and attention to it,
you get better at it.
So if you've got any laughs at all you can get,
you might not be doing it the right way,
but that's part of the process,
right?
Yeah.
I think George Carlin said,
no matter how bad a comedian is,
there's always one joke in his act that I go,
God,
I wish I wrote that joke.
And if you have that one joke,
it means you're capable of writing one.
Yes.
And sometimes your life changes and it puts you in a different space that makes
you a better comedian,
whether it's your performance of your writing,
but we go and comedy is,
it's a,
uh,
you're displaying what's going on inside of you.
When you're on stage,
on some level,
your anger,
your fear,
whatever it is,
it comes out in your performance.
And so if something changes fundamentally in your life,
sometimes it's getting married,
sometimes your father dies,
whatever.
You see people change,
they get sober and they can,
they can suddenly get good.
Yeah.
It can happen.
If it's like anything else in your life,
you run into someone,
they lost a hundred pounds.
Like what the fuck?
You lost a hundred pounds.
How did you do it?
I just made a change.
I just decided I'm not doing that anymore.
I'm going to live my life different.
And then I started riding that momentum and then here we are 16 months later.
Yeah.
That could happen with anything.
I remember Jim Norton when he started,
wasn't that funny,
struggled and all of a sudden boom found his voice.
He's fucking great.
Yeah.
It's weird when someone can't find their voice,
right.
It's like there's that uncertainty of life.
Is this going to work out?
Yeah.
My wasting my time then find it.
Or not or not.
You know.
And,
and again,
it's dependent also about how good are you at recognizing when you fucking up
how good at you or do you gloss over mistakes or do you examine them and learn
from them?
Cause if you gloss over,
God damn,
it takes forever to figure it out because you've got to play little games with
yourself and pretend you didn't do bad.
So if you didn't do bad,
you don't feel bad.
If you don't feel bad,
you're not going to change.
Like that's part of the reason that exists,
that,
that horrible feeling when you fuck something up like
that is so that's the,
the back,
that's the biological buzz.
Like,
hey fuck face,
you lost.
This is bad.
Figure this out.
But if you can lie to yourself,
you don't feel that ballsy.
Like,
oh mum didn't find it.
It was amazing.
[inaudible] crowd socked.
Well that's why getting sober can can affect that change because that's
ultimately what sobriety is.
You know,
if you have a problem,
you keep lying to yourself and you go,
you know,
I'm fine.
It was just last night.
I'm not gonna do that again.
Yeah.
Or you can say it was that crowd.
And then you know,
you'll see them struggle in some sort of weird way.
But comedy is,
it's so Aben flow dependent on day to day.
It's like talking to people,
you know,
you talking to people on a day to day basis,
like the people are different data day,
they subtly this way or that way and when you get enough people in a fucking
room and the drink and it's weird and then maybe you're a little tired and then
it comes off strange like,
God,
that's,
that sucked.
I need to get another set under my belt and then the next set like Paul,
I don't want it to be like that last set something up,
fire the fuck up and then,
oh,
this one's good,
good,
good.
Let me relax now.
Just I don't have to work that hard.
How tall is set?
Sorry
motherfucker.
And then you're like,
okay,
we're playing this game.
Are We?
Yeah,
that's the process.
Yeah.
And if I never have a better set than after
a bad set.
Always.
You're on your toes.
Yeah.
I tried to play a little game with myself where I pretend I just ate shit before
I go on.
Say the pretentious ain't shit,
here's my chance to redeem myself.
Let's go.
Ah,
yeah.
I play little games with myself sometimes.
I had the last night I had a,
who was sitting in the crowd?
Oh,
Andy kindler was sitting in the crowd with son of a bitch.
Sorry.
Just kidding.
Andy and a,
I love that idea.
And who the fuck else was out there?
Oh,
and a Harland Williams who are both like such interesting comedians that they're
watching me.
And you feel,
I usually don't give a fuck who's watching me.
But last night was the Improv and it was like nobody there and I felt like I
can't mail it in with a regular set.
I gotta fuck around here a little bit.
And I had just had a fucking great sad because it,
it made me dig in a little.
Yeah.
Yes,
yes.
That's one of the really good aspects about the comedy store these days too.
I said there's always people that you respect in the room.
Yeah.
Zoe,
someone there,
right is always Ronald whites there.
You know,
fast.
Jen gave me a big compliment the other night.
I,
one of my jokes that felt nice that Sebastian is the guy that struggled,
struggled kitty or early on,
I didn't know,
had a hard time,
had a hard time finding his voice and uh,
I didn't get a chance to see how good he had become.
And I watched him on showtime in a hotel room in Vegas.
I was there for a UFC or something and I watched a Sebastian,
I'll show showtime special.
And I was like,
God damn,
this is good.
I think I tweeted about it.
I eat either tweeted it or I emailed him.
I don't remember which,
where I was like,
that is fucking,
he's fucking good.
Yeah.
[inaudible] I watched him at the store the other night.
I mean,
Jesus,
he is bigger than life up there.
He just dominates the room.
She's very good.
And it took awhile.
It took awhile for him to find that thing.
And it happened while I was,
I was not around the comedy store's,
I really didn't get a chance to see his sets.
So before he was funny,
he was funny,
but he would have good sets and bad sets.
Who'd,
it was kind of struggling a little bit,
but then he found it.
Yeah,
just took his time.
Worked hard.
Always hustled.
Founded Jessel next,
last special.
I was so fucking good.
He's so good.
I mean it's like I've always liked them.
I've always enjoyed why and I don't watch people's whole hour.
Rarely,
but I've always watched his whole hours.
His writing is just so like intensely.
It's,
he's a craftsman.
He works hard and there is 2013 to Curtis personal hotel room laugh.
I also let's park.
Yes.
Sexy Bitch.
Yeah,
that was too,
so that was 2013 I had been a still out of the store.
I'd been out of the store for like a,
at that point shit was six years.
I hadn't been in the store in six years.
Specialist.
Excellent.
I just love guys like him and [inaudible] and Harlan's.
What one of those guys too that they're comedies is very specific to them.
They're like,
Brody was a great example that Brody's comedy is so specific to Brody.
Like if you see eight one eight to like die,
like why is that funny to you?
But to you,
would you like,
you immediately got a smile thinking about Brody saying it because comedy was so
specific to him.
I was a male model in Pakistan.
I was on the cover of camel beat.
Oh,
he was so funny.
We would ask him to do those jokes to and do the male model joke.
Hey,
you'd yell out to them.
Brody,
did you ever do any modeling?
Funny ask yet.
Brogan supportive.
I go,
Brody,
how did you get to the store tonight?
Laci,
Yana God north took it to sand the send day.
He would just say names of roads in La for five minutes and it was funny.
For whatever reason,
God,
I miss that guy.
He was like,
to me it was always like he was trying to make people laugh and he was also
trying to blow himself up.
He was trying to fill himself up.
He was like,
he was doing self affirmations with his comedy.
He wasn't boasting.
He was trying to convince himself that he was good enough to be up
there forever.
In my office.
I had a photo laminated photo that said office depot employee of the month and
it was Brody.
He took this photo.
It was like what he was using as a head shot.
I kept it just to give you a smile.
Yeah,
I was riding,
I put it up on my little cork board.
See if you can find that man.
I needed to get another one of those.
I don't know what the fuck happened to it
when he died.
I've never seen,
I don't think I've ever seen a turnout for a comedian dying.
Is it the way his memorial was that was laminated in my office.
Please do me a favor and print that up and let's get it.
Get that turned into another one that I put in my office because I,
uh,
somewhere in the move from,
um,
this studio from the old studio,
the studio,
I lost it,
but I always had that in my office.
It's just to look at just cause Brody was just so Brody.
Yeah,
he was just open,
raw and he,
you know,
he was one of those guys where you really have to be there.
You have to see him.
Yeah.
He's,
he's not,
he doesn't translate.
No one translates a hundred that's a dirty little secret about comedy specials.
You don't translate 100% of what you're experiencing when you're in that room.
That's why you're writing has to be even sharper and your,
your act outs have to be even sharper.
Everything has to be tightened down because you're not experiencing the physical
presence of all the audience members and the comedian all in this room together
because it's an intangible.
Right.
So if like going to see you live at the Wilbur theater,
if that's 100% watch new on Netflix is like 80% yeah.
The takeaway,
all the other people,
there's no other people there.
It's just you.
You can pretend they're there,
but they're not there.
So you don't have that feeling of being in a public place with a bunch of other
people which lights you up and then you don't have the comic that you came to
see right in front of you.
You don't have that.
Yeah,
you don't have the air.
You're all sharing the same air.
You're all in the room together.
You feel each other and some sort of a weird way,
so it's like 20% of every show
is also the momentum of like if you cut,
if you come to a comedy show,
you're surrounded by people that have an agenda to laugh.
They got a babysitter,
they paid money,
they sat down.
They are motivated to laugh and so now you're surrounded by,
if you're the Wilbur theater,
you've got a thousand people that all have that energy together.
You're sitting in your underwear under a blanket on a couch watching a show.
Yeah.
It's 80% though.
For the most part.
Yeah.
Maybe s might be in the 70s 79% what's the best standup comedy special of all in
your mind?
There are error dependent.
The thing about them is none of them really last.
They're not,
it's a comedy is one of the most,
um,
rapidly depreciating art forms in the culture in terms of its staying power and
try it.
Try and watch a movie we loved in the 80s try to watch a comedy movie.
My kids,
let's get me and they go,
why are you showing me garbage?
Yeah.
A few of them stand up blues,
blues brothers.
Sure.
Yeah.
But does it really,
it stands up because it's a classic,
but if it came out today,
would it be that much on the classic?
Probably not.
Things change.
They evolve in comedy.
They evolve rapidly and they're unforgiving.
Like I always say Lenny Bruce,
who I think is the main guy that started this whole thing,
he started it.
I mean there was other guys that were kind of doing it,
you know,
there's Mort Sahl,
there's a few guys who were doing,
you know,
some similar stuff.
I'm sure that didn't become famous.
But as far as guys that became famous at that time who are genuinely regarded
almost universally as being brilliant comedians.
Lenny Bruce was the Mac Daddy,
like he was a guy who did all the television shows.
He did all those shows and they wanted him to come on and he was brilliant and
he would go on there with great material and it was clean and then he morphed,
you know,
he just kept expanding and morphing and he got more into drugs and just started,
just just at the end of his career was really losing its fucking mind.
He was just fighting these obscenity cases and he was taught going on stages,
videos of him.
You could watch videos of him of that.
He could buy that.
I bought VHS tapes of back in the day where he would read the transcripts of his
trial on stage and people would like tell jokes,
come on,
where's the fucking jokes?
Like in the end he just completely went off the rails.
Right.
But his,
his steps I think were the first steps of modern standup comedy.
So anything he did was the greatest thing of all time back then.
You watch it now and then it doesn't hold on.
Holland does not hold up at all at all.
Neither does a lot of other books.
Prior holds up.
Prior holds out.
Yeah.
Prior holds up.
Lear,
um,
uh,
Hicks holds up,
but in a weird way.
Yeah.
Hix holds up in a way where you're,
you're realizing like,
wow,
this guy was doing some shit that no one else was doing back then.
Like young man on acid realized that life is just,
you know,
the whole bit that he does about positive stories in the,
in the news.
I remember exactly how the bit worse,
but it's hilarious.
Bit like that's a brilliant pit.
Yeah.
Well crafted bit.
He had a lot of those old people should do stunts in movies.
Yeah.
That was,
yeah.
I mean,
he had some great shit,
man.
They were great bits.
He was a different guy.
What he did is he like made people,
um,
in the audience think about ideas that you probably wouldn't have thought about
if not for his act.
And he challenged you to be smarter.
Like though there's part of that,
one of the things that Hicks was doing,
it was like he was his like,
Kinison went this way,
right?
Kinison was like,
Ronald Reagan,
the fucking president.
We're going to kick ass.
Yeah,
he went.
But he was also smart and he had great points.
Like the only reason why that bit about the African people that were starving to
death,
that bed about those late night television shows,
which is one of his darkest pits ever,
and one of his best bits.
But this,
it,
it worked because he was smart because he had points that were irrefutable.
It wasn't just these African kids starving to death.
Let me tell you what's funny about that.
Nothing's funny about that.
It was him saying,
why don't you feed them?
You're right.
And,
and then he would have these kind of bits that were fucked up,
but there was so well crafted.
You like,
Jesus,
this guy,
this is so good.
And so for then he was the greatest of all time when kid isn't came along,
man,
he was a mother fucker.
No one had ever seen anything like that before.
Yeah.
I remember how much you were affected by him,
you and Mike McDonald.
He was fucking Mike McCarthy.
Mccarthy.
Fuck comedy Barbaria.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
We both were huge.
Kinison fast.
He just made me think,
oh,
that's comedy too.
I didn't know you could do that if that's a different thing.
This guy's screaming.
I was married twice
and he was fat and he had a Baret od overcoat and he would come into the stern
show drunk after being up all night and do without a doubt.
The best darn appearances of all time.
Yeah.
You know his story too,
right?
Do you know what chair?
Right?
You know what flipped him though?
Head injury hit by a car.
No Shit.
Yup.
Him and Roseanne.
Both the same story.
Wow.
Yup.
There's something about traumatic brain injuries that lead to a lot of people
being extremely impulsive and they wind up doing a lot of wild shit.
Tj Miller hold themselves.
Yeah.
He had some kind of a brain thing happened to him and he needed a,
he got treated for it and he recovered.
But that's when he started acting kind of erratic.
Whoa.
Yeah.
It happens.
People get irrational and you get impulsive,
get very impulsive.
Happens with ex football players,
ex fighters.
Right.
Um,
but that's what happened to Sam.
He got hit by a car.
His brother wrote a book about it called brother Sam as brother Bill.
And uh,
that's one of the things it talks about.
Like Sam was like this normal kid.
It gets hit by a fucking car and then all of a sudden he's is wild man.
Like wild demon and no control.
Just didn't give a fuck.
Right.
You know,
that's a guy that I wish I met and like,
Fuck God.
Damn it with a low,
I really wanted to meet that goal.
We did mean heck we softly,
we were in the room with him.
We didn't hang out with them.
Or he said hi to him in the green room.
That was about it.
Oh yeah.
I always think of that when like a young comic comes to the Green Room to say hi
to me.
I always think fucking be
nice to this kid because this means more to him than you can imagine.
Fuck yeah.
Just the fact that Hicks acknowledged I was alive.
Yeah.
We got,
we've got amazing comedy education,
my friend.
Yeah.
It's so lucky to have a job where you could say what you want to and you don't
have to worry like that.
Poor Lpg,
a guy,
Cork Golf Guy,
kid suspended.
Well,
especially now because like it really TV,
doesn't matter.
Being banned from TV doesn't end your career anymore.
No.
Look if fucking Jim Jeffrey says some shit that's fucking crazy.
He says his whole bit about rape that like,
I couldn't believe they,
it was on Sirius XM radio the other day and like,
you know,
his show got canceled.
He's got another fucking show.
But without those,
it doesn't matter.
You get,
you get your shit up on the Internet,
you do a podcast,
the tour.
You don't ever have to do the tonight show again.
You don't have to do,
you know?
Yeah.
There was only a few avenues back then.
Yeah,
Santa Fe.
Right.
So those would be good.
Yeah.
You just have to be interesting or not even,
man.
I mean there's a lot of fucking people that just do makeup tutorials and then
make millions.
The world's crazy.
Yeah,
but don't think that it's supposed to be fair.
Like all those guys back in Boston.
Hey,
what the fuck I killed that night.
Same thing.
Yeah.
I don't think this world's supposed to be fair.
This thing is not this thing.
No one knows what the fuck is going on.
This kid is making $30 million review and toys on Youtube.
Yep.
That's just how it is.
Cause he loves toys and that's what he started.
Dylan,
what do you love?
No,
do it.
It's just that's how it is.
Like you're getting upset about that.
It doesn't help anybody.
Yeah.
The kid makes 30 million review and toys.
Go figure it out.
So you're thinking,
oh yeah,
we'll get him mad at the kid.
Fuck that kid.
Yeah,
I got money.
I just want 1 million a year.
At all and want from you.
Come on kid.
Hey,
he'll give it to me.
You're not even gonna use it.
You're seven.
I was a veteran.
It some veteran reviewing Tillys online.
Get 12 [inaudible] is for good little queers.
It's fucking dog.
This little doll.
This fucking soldier never saw the shit.
I saw the shit.
Yeah.
This is this fake GI Joe Bullshit fucking soldier.
What,
what is the next thing?
Like it's not veterans review and toys.
It's not going to be that.
But what would be the next thing?
The next thing.
So I think it's gotta be,
it's gotta be something that,
that like lets people interact more.
That's what people are looking for.
I mean,
you've got social apps,
but how do you take a social app and make it something that you sit down and
watch every day as programming?
Right.
Let's do that.
What's the clip show or what's the,
who is the host that can take social media and do like with talk soup did with
uh,
with video clip,
with cable,
cable TV shows.
How do you capture social media and present it to people?
In a way that is more linear.
Well,
the thing is like everybody's sort of agreeing that social media is insanely
addictive and that people are sort of in denial about it.
Most people have a real issue with it.
Yeah.
Most people that I know,
um,
or their phones there stare at their phones all day,
they can't help it.
They're that drawn to the next text message.
They want the next tweet,
tweet,
whatever it is.
Yeah.
They want,
they want to see that next Facebook posts and Instagram posts.
They're addicted to it.
And what,
what we're doing is making it more,
more addictive.
They're making it better.
Right?
Everything keeps getting better.
The cameras keep getting better.
The apps are better,
the algorithms,
they figure out how long it should take to reload and to move to another page
and went to present the next,
the next graphic that all that stuff is the same guys that figured out how slot
machines should work in Vegas to keep you putting quarters into them.
They figure out how often you need to win and uh,
how,
how loud the bells should be.
And they extract your data,
right,
and then they sell that data and then they make infinite amounts of money and
they want to keep you on the tit and so they're going to keep that touch.
You see all kinds of new stuff.
What about these anti-vaxxers?
They're moving into your neighborhood.
What?
Fucked.
Yeah.
Next.
You know you're embroiled in a Facebook anti vaccs debate that keeps you up in
the middle of the night.
You go back to chuck the post.
What the fuck did you right the fuck did he wrote,
Oh,
he's got to go to sleep and now I'm going to let him know,
oh,
my COO.
My piece of my mind.
How many people are just ready to blow their fucking brains out sand in front of
the computer at night and arguments with people on Facebook?
Yeah.
First of all,
that is one of the worst ways to communicate.
I understand that it's a really effective way to communicate,
but just text messages,
just text,
just writing things back.
It's like one of the crude is ways that we know it's,
he might as well send a raven.
Yeah,
really right.
Wrap a fucking a piece of paper around that Ravens Foot and send it and I'll
read it when I,
okay,
this is what he means.
Yeah.
Like we could talk to each other now.
Like it's,
we should limit the amount of texting we do.
I really think,
well what did
about video texts.
Yeah.
I haven't seen much of that.
A lot of,
hey Joe,
what's happened to man?
Give me a call later
sand.
That's cause you're white.
Yesterday,
Wiz Khalifa was here and he was saying that everybody facetimes now.
Hell yeah.
And the,
I know this for a fact because I was taking a shit when killer Mike facetime to
me.
So he is also a member of the prestigious community and yeah,
he's their fucking,
they're facetime each other now,
which I'm for.
Yeah.
That's great.
That's better.
That's connecting everybody.
No,
you called me on the phone yesterday.
Yes.
And you were like,
that's it.
I'm done with texting.
I'm only calling in and I was like that Joey Joey Diaz.
That's yeah,
I'm doing that now.
She only gets offended and almost angry if you email them.
I mean,
I'll text people
details for things and addresses and stuff like that.
But if it's somebody that I like I like,
I mean I'm,
I'm wanting to talk to them,
say hi.
And there's other thing that's happened when you keep in touch with people with
texts,
you realize how rarely you talked to them on the phone.
You know,
there's a few of my friends that I hardly ever see.
Yeah.
So I've been trying to make time for like dinner plans,
go to hang out with you know,
friends and just,
just instead of always working.
Yeah.
So like I'm always every like plan that I make in terms of uh,
what I do with my times,
either family related or work related.
Yeah.
And I feel like I have got to,
I've kind of like reach out to friends,
boring like a one on one face to face sort of.
It was just this comprehensive study that started in the 1930s by Harvard
University about what causes happiness.
And the number one thing was friendship.
People talk about family,
they talk about work and you overlook community.
You know,
friendship means it's almost like,
like sometimes I feel like I really love my wife.
I got so fucking lucky.
She,
I hear her voice and I get happy when she walks in the door.
I jump up,
I want to talk to her.
But to the point where on a Saturday night we just go out to dinner.
We just go do something during the day.
We just hang out.
And sometimes I think I should be spending more time with friends,
you know?
Especially since then I can talk shit about her.
There you go.
Good call.
But you know,
it's really,
it really is like,
you know,
you don't carve out that time.
And this,
this study said that gratitude and friendship by the two main things for
happiness.
You're married to your friend.
That's beautiful too.
Right?
Um,
when you have friends,
when you have people that you can confide in and talk to,
you have different perspectives,
different points of view.
Whether,
I mean it's always best if it's in your house like it was your wife who'd be
amazing,
you know,
um,
very,
very pro getting your shit together in terms of uh,
like the,
the way you run a relationship,
right?
Like how nice are you?
How,
how,
how well do you guys get along?
And I think he should extend not just to your,
like your spouse but also to like all your friends.
Like how nice are your friends?
Like what,
how little bullshit do you give them?
How much compliments do you give them a hum.
Uh Hum.
How objective are you with the way you guys interact with each other?
How often do you tell them that you care about them?
How often do you take them for granted?
I'm very pro analysis and I think all of us could,
we could do well to analyze like how we interfaced with each other.
Cause I think most most problems that people have,
they,
it's like one thing happens,
then this thing happens and that thing happens.
But if the first thing didn't happen with the second thing have happened,
if the first slight didn't happen,
if the first way you greeted someone,
it was with a big smile and a handshake and maybe a little roll,
the whole conversation with a role that a totally different way.
And then afterwards someone said,
hey,
I thought you were mad at Greg.
You know when I was with the way he came over and shook my hand,
smiled at me and I'm like,
Oh,
who cares?
What am I worried about?
Whereas if he came over with an attitude,
oh,
this fucking guy.
And then he's like,
oh that fucking guys hasn't dropped it yet.
Yeah,
we're still,
we're still arguing about the stupid fucking thing.
You know,
I'm writing,
no,
it's half of it is the way we interact with each other.
Right?
Male,
female,
boy,
whatever the fuck.
It's just human beings.
Half of the way human beings like the,
the way things go.
Half of it is how we interact with each other.
He had the energy,
like I go to the comedy store sometimes and if I show up and like I show up
three minutes before my spot and then I parked the car and I'm walking in and
somebody I like,
we'll say hi to me,
you know,
I'll see,
uh,
you know,
dove Davidow for somebody I haven't seen in awhile and he says what's up?
And I kind of brushed past him cause I'm late.
That fucks up the relationship because that person feels like,
oh I thought I meant a lot to that guy.
So it's like shit,
I got to show up early and be and think before I walk in,
be available to people because you know,
it's,
it is,
you're right,
it can be very subtle how you shake someone's hand,
you like don't hug them or hug them.
Yup.
Friend of mine goes the other day.
Uh,
we played beach volleyball on Sundays.
That's my big social things.
We 15 years I've been playing with the same guy.
Yeah,
that's great exercise too.
It's great.
And we call ourselves the shirts because we're the only guys on the beach
playing with our shirts on
and were fucking terrible.
We never get any better.
And uh,
and so,
um,
so we,
we go out and I,
I hug,
I showed up and I hugged everybody.
And then this one guy,
Evan goes to me,
he goes,
uh,
you know,
I don't think you should hug everybody all the time.
I think a hug should be like for a special moment.
So it actually means something.
And I go,
you have enough intimacy problems and don't fucking put them on me.
I'll,
I won't hug you,
but I'm fucking hugging everybody else.
I love it.
I love a moment where I can hug somebody.
The
comedy store should be called the hug festival.
Yeah.
Right.
Places all about hugs and everyone's always hugging everybody.
Yeah.
You know,
the more people that you can have like that in your life,
more people that you want to hug,
the better off you are.
That's,
you know,
a,
a community of people that you actually care about.
I hugged the shit out of my kids.
Yeah.
It bums me out when people don't like to know as bums me out when people don't
like to,
to hug their kids.
Man.
The kids.
It's a bummer.
It's a real bummer.
You know,
when you know someone who doesn't like being a parent,
it's rough.
Yeah.
Cause you know you,
you know that that feeling,
it's all,
I mean it's just one of the things about having children.
Do you realize it's all about trying to foster love.
It's all about that.
It's all about you want them to be loving people to meet other loving people is
like,
this is possible.
This is possible.
If this family can get along and we all love each other and care about each
other.
So much weight,
why can't the human race,
why can't all these people get along better?
Why can't they?
They can.
In the ideal circumstances,
you're out.
You're under ideal circumstances and most people aren't.
Well,
it's fear.
I think that that's what keeps people from being vulnerable.
Yeah.
And hugging and expressing how they feel about each other and supporting like
unconditioned,
unconditional love is getting rid of the fear.
You can't be afraid that this love is going to turn on you and this person is
going to hurt you.
Right.
And you have to have had that happen a few times.
So you're like,
well,
I know what that is.
Yeah.
I must've been annoying.
Right.
Yeah.
Listen analysis,
it's part of the problem.
Yeah.
We're all part of the problem.
Yeah,
man.
It's um,
I think it's an interesting time for people to communicate though.
I don't think anybody is a really gotten to the bottom of things in later.
I mean,
in the past,
the way people are trying to get to the bottom of things now there's a lot of
noise.
What do you mean emotionally?
I think emotionally,
the way we communicate with each other,
even the way people are examining government and examining foreign policy and
examining the offices of the president and examining voting and the electoral
process and there's,
there's things that people are in analyzing now and looking at the,
I think because of all the chaos of the Internet,
we kind of lose sight of all the crazy shit that it's doing.
It's doing so many different things.
And changing things so much that it's,
it's rewiring the way people are looking at the world itself.
Yeah,
and that's why all these fucking drugs are getting legalized.
The giant part of why silicide wind is getting legalized now.
It's decriminalized in Denver.
Marijuana's being decriminalized left and right.
It's because people here,
people like you and me and anyone else that has a brain that understands about
drug laws,
hear them talking about it and you go,
this is crazy.
You can't lock people up for mushrooms and you should take them.
Yeah,
she fucking take him.
They'll probably fix your brain.
They'd probably give you a new perspective and make you realize you were being a
dick.
It's half of what's wrong with us,
right?
We're,
we're just worried about how we interface with each other and we see the same
foot.
You see,
you're saying the internet is giving people insights and information that's
changing the way we live?
I think so for sure.
I think the access to information,
because the stream is so large,
so much nonsense comes through it that you lose perspective of all the positive
changes taking place because of the Internet.
All these drug legalization things I don't think would ever be possible without
all of the information that's been distributed online,
whether it's through videos or through people talking about,
or podcasts or comedy routines or just facts were facts based.
You know,
news
organizations start putting out the,
here's the real facts about marijuana and you know,
and fatalities and this is this.
These are the real facts about where the money's going,
how it's going right now to fund cartels and how this is crazy because we're,
we're literally creating an organized crime empire because we're making
something that everybody wants.
Right?
All that stuff is available now.
You can't scratch it.
We were just talking about,
yes,
that's another one.
You can't squash it with propaganda like they couldn't have had,
they could just kind of decide what narrative gets played out in the newspapers.
Right.
You can't do that anymore.
Did you read that article I sent you about stories versus facts?
Yes,
I did.
And that's the,
you know,
uh,
you've all Herati,
right?
Yes.
The guy that wrote sapiens and it basically says that,
you know,
stories,
Trump facts and that basically we are a culture.
The human,
the human species has always believed the myth,
whether it's religion or whether it's a political dogma that we are more apt to
ignore facts that don't support a story.
Uh,
because telling facts being factual is difficult because sometimes that fact
doesn't jive with what you thought was true and now you have to rectify that and
that's hard.
And so it's easy for us to just say,
you know,
we're all,
Jesus came and when we die our sins will be forgiven and we're supposed to do
this.
And then if facts come up to negate how,
how long ago,
man,
you know,
all the,
all the things we know from archeology that negate everything that's in the
Bible.
Then the story,
you still have 60% of the,
of our country doesn't believe that the,
they think that you planted is 6,000 years old.
I think it's 46%.
Yeah,
yeah.
46% of the country thinks that,
but they only think of it in terms of they won't denounce the Bible.
Do they really?
I mean,
if you had a gun to their head,
they really think that,
I don't think it's that high.
I think it's a lot of horse shit.
I think there's a lot of people that say,
if that's what the Bible says,
is that what the Bible says?
The Bible says,
my want to believe the stitcher tail and Bert,
I told him that's what the Bible says.
Mama good boy.
Yeah,
there's a lot of that.
When he's with his friends and he cracks open a beer and he's like,
what the fuck does my Mama know about?
Oh,
the fucking earth is,
yeah,
there's a lot of people,
little gold.
She is just try and know a lot of people go to church on Sunday because
culturally that's what you do.
It doesn't mean they subscribed to all that stuff,
but then you've got,
you know,
the uh,
every four years the government puts out a,
an environmental study that is done by I think 12 different departments in the
government.
And it's considered the quintessential update on where the environment is
internationally.
And that came out in November and it was damning about pollutants.
And uh,
the administration put it out on black Friday,
the day after Thanksgiving at three o'clock in the morning and they buried it.
And in it is everything about global warming you ever needed
to know and they're no longer calling it global warming.
They're no longer calling,
um,
uh,
it's no longer fossil fuel.
It's freedom.
What is the new thing they're calling it?
Freedom,
freedom,
juice,
some like that.
Jesus come,
they're literally changing the name of fossil fuels.
This is the Trump administration gas.
Natural gas is being rebranded to freedom gas.
Wow.
That's just like some team America,
world police type Shit.
And it's like people that want to deny global warming,
it's like the facts are there in unrefuted.
I don't think anyone's denying that the planet's warming.
Right.
I think they're denying how much of an impact human beings have and whether or
not it's worth changing the way we do in industry.
Yeah.
And whether or not we're need to impose more restrictions on,
on exhaust fumes.
And I mean factories,
how much you're trying to drive by a factory and you see that pillow ing smoke
and yet here you're like,
how the fuck are we allowing that?
Yeah.
Like there's places to this day.
Will you drive there and you go,
oh,
this group gets to pollute the air that the babies breathe.
Yeah,
they do for this business.
Whatever the fuck they doing.
What are they making tires they get to pollute the air.
I mean what is the worst polluter?
Like when you drive by a factor and you see the,
the black smoke shooting in the sky.
Like what the fuck are they doing?
Cruise ships.
Oh,
I think I read there the number one polluter.
We did a thing where we were trying to figure out was it with 'em
who was it with?
Um,
someone was explaining how much devastation cruise ships do in terms of the
amount of fuel that they burn and the impact that they have.
And the fact,
oh,
it was volunteering.
Thomas,
was it her
sounds
they were talking about like each cruise ship,
like how much actual fuel they burn off.
It's preposterous.
I think I read there the biggest burners of fossil fuels in the world.
So giant fucking metal thing in the water.
Yeah.
You ever tried to push up fucking row boat?
It's a lot of work.
It's a lot of work,
man.
How,
what assholes are people where they built something like the titanic?
Like just what kind of an asshole says,
not only am I gonna make it out of metal,
I'm like,
can we just use a bunch of small boats and get,
nope.
Nope,
nope,
nope.
Nope.
I'm going to make the biggest,
biggest boat ever.
And when I wrote on it,
even God can't sync it.
I mean,
I'm Noah.
Imagine what an asshole you have to be to write even God can't shake it.
Yeah.
On the side of the boat.
Oh,
is that what they wrote?
Just,
Oh,
that's hilarious.
Wasn't that?
Is that,
that's a fact,
right?
That better not be an urban myth.
I think it said on the side of the titanic.
Even God can't sync it.
Yeah.
They weren't one of these people would be excited and they're going nowhere.
Cruise ship,
just going nowhere.
Well,
it was something to do back then,
man.
Imagine living back then.
Oh,
I know the titanic quiz to conditioning and that was on TV.
Yeah,
titanic 1920s yeah,
the roaring that we're making one and so out to tank to name did it.
Did it say what?
I think it said that.
That's a quote.
Someone said an employee,
I don't know if it was written on him,
but I got the loan was written 1911 oh,
it's a launch code.
It was 1911 quote rather 1911 fuck live in then it's more than a hundred years
ago.
Okay.
At cave people where they back then we were,
I said,
what can a cave people with a back then you can have x ray machines.
How the fuck they sit?
Your broken leg?
What'd they do?
The thing on the cruise ships,
it's a video about how much they pollute.
Whoa.
One ship or watch a cruise ship pollute as much as 13 million cars in one day is
what this video is called.
Wow.
No Shit.
Whoa.
Hold.
It has gotten so much bigger over to over time.
Holy Shit.
19 million cars.
Let's just ban cruise ships.
Wow.
Trump does zero Trump cruise ship.
Why doesn't he ever crucially,
cause he hasn't thought of it yet.
He's going to hear this podcast.
Huh?
Let's wrap this up cause I gotta pee really badly.
Gregory,
you'll be with me tonight at the Improv shows.
Good Times.
Mani Franklin,
Allie Makowski.
You've got some dates.
Got some dates coming up.
People.
I'm going to be in lovely Atlanta at the punchline.
June 6th Oh shit.
Pops up.
It's back.
It's in a different location.
How is it?
It's great.
It's a,
it's more intimate.
Woo.
Yeah.
Rice.
And then I'll be in Tampa at side splitters on June 13th to the 15th and then I
will be in Buffalo,
New York at a helium comedy club.
And June 27th through the 29th Coda fits dog.com for tickets.
The podcast is fits dog radio and then childish is my other podcast with Alison
Rosen.
How fucking professionals.
He,
it's like you do it for a living.
Oh wait.
All right,
bye everybody.
How long was it?